that they would just print it. >> uncritical. I think when
you quote somebody, it's Wired's responsibility to get the quote
accurately. That's
>> what they're responsible for.
>> I don't know that he knows the exact contracts. I'm
saying he is lying because he is saying it's debunked with no
evidence that it's debunked and not even actually addressing
the actual allegations made in the article. >> You could
say that it might be like a sneaky way around it. You could say,
>> are they paying anybody who doesn't
>> Um, I don't know. I don't know. every single content
creator that is under chorus. I haven't looked them all up. >> What
the does electioneer mean? >> Dark money. There there is
a debate around that. Some liberals feel that we should use dark
money. Some liberals argue against it like that, you know, that
is a debate. But I think what most people would agree on if you
ask the public and certainly this is what I think like you know
any sort of ethical expert would would say as well is that disclosure
is really important and if you are take if you are presenting
yourself as a journalist online which several of these content
creators are presenting themselves as news sources or journalists
that you should >> Oh yeah. So hold on. I'm literally reading
this article right now. She So she just said that she never claimed
that the chorus was secretive, but that the where they're getting
their money is secretive. Literally, there is a sentence here
that says, "Now Democrats hope the secretive chorus incubator
program funded by the powerful liberal dark money group called
the 1640 fund." And then it goes on further. It literally states
it is a secretive chorus creator incubator program. >> What
is it? offer fun to take part in a secretive program. So I think
uh chorus is not secretive but the program might be secretive
or aspects of the program might be secretive. >> Well,
no
has been reported about a lot. So I think she's just referring
to it that
>> No, no, no. What I'm saying is she just said like maybe
45 seconds ago that she didn't refer to like chorus as being
secretive, just that the money was
>> Yeah. Go ahead. Yeah.
>> So, so she didn't refer to secret as >> calling
1630 secret of dark money. >> No, she this is the quote.
Now, Democrats hope that the secretive chorus creator incubator
program,
funded by the powerful liberal. So, yeah, the
>> the chorus creator, incubator, the whole thing. That's
the whole thing. >> The program No, chorus. There's a lot
of
>> chorus creator incubator program. Is that not what it
is? That's the program. It's not the whole thing. Like chorus
has been advertised publicly by a lot of people, but there's
language in the contract that says you shouldn't disclose that
you're being funded by >> I'm sorry. Is that not a creative
in creator incubator program? Is that not >> Chorus has
multiple other things they do than just the incubator program.
>> Like what? >> Yes. Their incubator program is
what they is that what it's being called? Uh this is the thing
that they started up a month ago. >> Yeah. like chorus
has existed since November and the incubator program has only
existed for the past like month >> or maybe two months
now. >> So, okay. So, but this is directly separate in
this sentence. It's directly separate than the powerful liberal
dark money group 1630.
>> Like it's separated. So, it's it's referring to the
chorus incubator program as secretive.
>> Yeah. And I think the reporting there, the factual reporting
that leads to the secretive declaration on that, maybe she misspoke
here and said she'd never call a chorus in any way secretive.
But I do believe that the the secretive element is saying that
you can't disclose that you're being paid by this program. >> You
can't disclose that you're being paid at all is the argument.
>> Um I So I think there was some argument
>> Yeah, I think you need written permission. Yeah, something
like that. But I I I'm not totally sure on that one. That one
is um how do I put it? Like that one is the one that's caused
a lot of contention. And I think Chorus might not want to stand
behind that. like they might actually like they put that in for
I believe what five uh the 501c4 like to maintain their non-
electioneering nonpartisan status that like hey you can't just
um you can't just disclose if you're going to do mostly political
content you can't just disclose you're being funded by us right
cuz it's not meant to be an ad we're not putting our name behind
you we're putting money behind you as like a creator but not
in terms of your political messaging is like what they want so
I think that's what it's trying to do right >> and according
to is it's saying that according to Wired that they
would be kicked off cut off financially if they were so much
as to acknowledge that they were a part of the program. So, by
Wired's own argument, there is not a single creator on planet
Earth that has ever acknowledged they've been a part of the incubator
program that is still >> um and I believe, as far as I
know,
um other than the ones that are disclosed via the article, none
of them have come out and said I'm being like sponsored by this
uh this incubator program or how much you're being paid or like
the Yeah. the overall financial engagement. So people say I disclosed
I was a part of chorus but they disclosed in like November that
they were a part of chorus before this program ever started.
>> So so it is to your knowledge that there isn't a single
creator at all ever that has disclosed that they are part of
the incubator program. >> Uh not I so I don't think there
has been one or there hadn't been one to my knowledge that had
disclosed they were being paid by the incubator program before
this article came out. Yeah. I don't I don't believe so. I do
think I do think that they had been >> you're talking about
the Tik Toks that express interest in being part of it like before
the program, right? >> It might be Hold on. Uh Porter Beller
is saying it's about payments. It might be about disclosing exactly
how much you're being paid.
>> I don't think you should have to do that. No, I think
that's a weird thing to do. >> You don't have to. No, you
don't have to. I'm saying they were prevented from
>> prevented from >> not not have to be >> prevented
from. >> Is that a problem?
>> I think that's weird, especially as a Democrat cuz you're
taking away a lot of uh bargaining rights or something. I mean,
sure, you could you could say that's weird, but like knowing
exactly how much making it public exactly how much each individual
creator is being paid. Like
>> Well, preventing them from saying so,
>> Yeah. Well, sorry. Yeah. Prevent the I mean, they know
how much they're getting paid. Why is that so wrong? >> I
don't think they have to disclose how much they're getting paid.
I think probably you could disclose that disclose that you are
being paid. That it would be like a substantial amount. Um and
I believe they're I believe it's saying that you know all disclosures
around payments
were a part of this this uh part right well no according to the
sentence it's it's that if you even acknowledge that you are
a part of the program you are cut off financially not even that
if you acknowledge that you are being paid if you acknowledge
I am exerson is a part of the incubator program they would cut
you off financially that is what wired is claiming Well,
uh, let's see. Uh, where are the Hold on a second. I'm going
to I'm going to look at Destiny's document here, and we'll see
if we find a counterpoint for that. >> So, I I don't
>> This does this feels like standard
things that you would see in an employment contract where
not like it isn't often that you get fired or let go for things
like this, but like if they want to let you go, they pile these
things on. >> Yeah. So, I have not seen a specific thing
from before this article dropped that one of these people has
said, "I'm being paid to be a part of this incubator program."
>> No. So, that that's not even Wyard's claim. Wyard's
claim is that if you state you are in the incubator program that
I'm in the incubator program. I I had not seen this before the
article had dropped. Maybe maybe there are some, right? Uh but
here's the other thing. um is article is the article's claim
that the contract language says that or that they know that to
be true because
that the contract stipulated they'd be kicked out and essentially
cut off financially if they even so much as acknowledge that
they are part of the >> So to be clear that's a quote that's
not a that's not a claim Wired's making. That's a claim that
somebody who is talking to Wired is making right wait is making
this claim by putting it inside of their article. They are putting
their weight behind it. It That is what happens to >> they're
explicitly saying it's those people. Now I think what what you
would do here normally is you would go and say okay is the reason
outside of that quote to make me think that's true. I believe
they also talk about contract stipulations that go down this
same line. So I would assume that those that the quote would
go with the contract stipulations that they reviewed and they
go oh this is a reasonable thing to >> Yes. So they're
putting their weight behind the claim. That's is that's what's
happening here. you know, based on the contract, right? >> Yeah.
Based on the contracts that they have, they're putting their
weight behind the the claim. >> Well, I would say when
they say creators told Wired, told Wired, that is a quote. That
is a quote. That is not them claiming that the contract even
says that, but we could look and see what they say the contract
claims. >> So, to put it inside of the article is to put
their weight behind you because you would you agree or disagree
that why? Okay. So, here so then this is going to be my next
question. You would say that if creators told Wired anything,
including that it just had a picture of David Pacman's co inside
of the contract, that they would just print >> Totally
uncritically.
>> I think when you quote somebody, it's Wired's responsibility
to get the quote
>> That's
what they're responsible for.
>> The claim is not theirs, but the claim does go along
with other information. So they're including a claim that that
does pair with information they've seen and it is not the exact
same information. So they have a claim based on the contracts.
The contracts show us that there are some stuff some restrictions
right about
uh like about disclosing. Creators told us that they felt that
the contract said they'd be kicked out if they were if they acknowledged
they were part of the program. Those are two different statements.
Those are two different claims in my opinion. >> Do do
you believe Wired is not vetting these sources or do you think
that they're just taking like random people at their word? No,
I think they probably would have gotten the contract from one
of these sources. >> Okay, so they're putting their weight
>> this article before we watch this >> Uh maybe
>> like I I don't So like I I know for a fact because I
read this all the time that this is not standard editorial practice
where they'll just go somebody said some random thing so we're
just going to print it. That's not how it works. No, no, no.
Hold on. >> They said a thing and there's somebody that
we have vetted to be somewhat reliable or to be uh uh >> I
can just give you I can just give you another thing that would
>> totally make sense, >> right? You're you're going
at like some uh restrictive contracts at Subway and they say,
"Okay, you know, this this employee came to us. They gave us
the contract. the contract seems to state that like under x,
y, and z conditions, they would be uh financially cut off from
uh from working at Subway or something. And then they print a
quote that the guy the guy comes in and says, "Yeah, I just feel
like if I talk about the money at all, I'll get kicked out."
And they say that that's a quote from that guy. >> Yeah.
So they're >> so they're talking about his feelings and
and how that that person feels. This is about how that person
feels, right? This is a quote that is about how that person feels,
right? And they're saying there's also contract language that
goes along with this. So the claim that they're making
they're putting their weight behind the idea that the contract
language would uh re reasonably lead a person to believe that
they can't acknowledge it. Yes. >> Yeah. That's what they're
So I don't why did we even start this? Wired is putting their
weight behind the claim that the contract language stipulates
to any a reasonable interpreter that you cannot talk about these
things. And just my simple question is has there been anybody
who has ever spoken about and you already said that to your knowledge
no has there been anybody who has ever spoken about the them
being a part of the incubator program? >> This goes to
the one update that's on the article. Um there was an update
somebody basically said okay they they did a zoom call at some
point after this and uh that for one they they do add that why
this guy didn't even though they reached out to him for comment
he didn't provide a comment right so there's a screenshot from
a zoom presentation that says
uh what is it include can publicly talk about their working at
chorus and chorus's connection to good influence both of which
wired has clarified we've also included comment so I think this
is basically there's like a a slide that says this is how you
can disclose it, >> Okay. Um, >> but I don't know
if that's about the financial disclosure and they haven't published
that slide either. >> So, I don't know if they were asked
not to publish that or what. >> Okay. But even still with
this being the case, like my my issue, there's so many issues.
I I feel like just off rip for this. Is should this be the expectation
that you need to be able to say like what specific part of the
program that you are a part of? >> How do you have issues?
who just read the article while we're watching this >> because
because I'm reading it while I'm listening to her explain it.
I could have issues with it with how she >> You're taking
money from something from let's say a source that donates to
politics, you could reasonably interpret that as some sort of
political action on the part of that that party, right? >> If
you believe that you shouldn't be able if you believe it's okay
to be prevented from disclosing money that is being like provided
for people who do political speech, I think that's crazy. I think
I think obviously disclosures are It's money
political speech. Even in the quote as read, as stipulated, it
just says that they couldn't state that they were a part of the
incubator program. And as she stated before, people have been
able to say that they're a part of chorus. The idea that like
you have to explicitly be able to stipulate that you're a part
of the incubator content creator incubator program. I don't think
that's necessary. As long as you disclose I'm a part of this,
I'm a part of this company, this organization, and I'm being
paid by this organization. I don't really see the huge issue.
I don't think you need to have like a line by line breakdown
of your explicit program that you're >> I would say that
that would be a good thing to to clarify and that I think a reasonable
person could say that they don't they don't feel like they're
partnered with course. They're just inside of that program, right?
And this is the only contact they've had with Chorus is about
this program. Then I think it would be reasonable for them to
interpret that as oh I can't disclose. And I think that could
be a clarification that fixes things like oh you can disclose
that you're being paid by chorus but don't disclose that you're
being paid as a part of the chorus content creator like thing
but I think that would have to be like very important that would
be very important to clarify and make clear to people that like
I don't think it's important you say I'm a part of the you know
this pilot program the whatever it is I forget the >> exact
stipulating it's stipulating the explicitly the and it's not
contested at least it didn't seem contested that you say you
were a part of Chorus and you were being paid by Chorus. There
were people who were saying that they were being paid by Chorus
prior to this article even being public. >> Contracts reviewed.
>> I'll just I'll just read this part here. The contracts
reviewed by Wired prohibit standard partnership disclosures declaring
that creators will not publicize the relationship with Chorus
or tell others that they're members of the program without Chorus's
prior written prior express consent. A screenshot from a slideshow
was shared with Wired following this article's publication by
Graeme Wilson, a lawyer working with Chorus that offers several
talking points if a member of the cohort wanted to discuss Chorus
publicly. They also forbid creators from disclosing the identity
of any funer and give Chorus the ability to force creators to
remove or correct content based solely on the organization's
discretion if that content was made at a chorus organized event.
So, this is very different from what the person said they felt.
This is >> that feels pretty standard to me. No, I feel
like that would be a part of any
group like ever is. Hey, >> did you disclose that you were
trying PV
>> Yeah, I did. The the the whole idea. >> Why? Because
I was allowed to. >> They didn't have they didn't have
a I would just assume PV would run things in a standard way.
You think it's standard to prevent disclosures when paying for
>> without consent? Yeah, I think it would be without consent
because what you're trying to avoid is you're trying to avoid
people going to specific events and being like, I'm here with
Progressive Victory or I'm here doing this with Progressive Victory
and then attaching their name to some kind of uh uh maybe it's
some kind of charity event or stuff like that. And then now they're
in legal trouble because well this person said that they're here
with progressive victory and they're not allowed to be doing
x amount because I know that political organizing and stuff like
that you can only do a certain amount um at a specific time in
specific places or whatever. And so now they're in a whole bunch
of legal trouble. So uh clearing that with people and being like
hey um you can only make these claims in certain pre-authorized
context that feels pretty standard. You know, that makes
all the sense in the world. >> Uh because otherwise they'd
be swarmed with legal trouble all the time. They'd be swarmed
with legal trouble literally all the time. >> What legal
trouble would they be in from somebody saying they're partnered?
I I don't actually know the legal trouble. >> I just gave
an example. I am at a charity event with progressive victory
or something like that. And then so their their campaign contributions
or whatever the uh uh you know is being restricted at the time,
they're going beyond their legal limits. And now they're in legal
trouble and now they need to explain, oh actually no, this person
wasn't here in an official capacity
this political group or entity. >> I don't know. What do
you mean legal
Wait, you don't so you know that when you're a some kind of uh
like political pack or group, you're you're like influencing
politics that you can only do it to a specific degree or specific
amounts of like monetary contribution or contribution um in a
what's it tangible monetary way? You can't just go like, "Yeah,
I'm going to just give hundred billion dollars of free press
or hundred billion dollars of this to whatever group." You have
limits. There's limits. Okay, that is what you're trying to avoid.
That is what they're trying to avoid is going beyond those limits.
>> I don't believe Chorus has um explicit limits
placed on it in terms of what they can fund going towards their
thing. The problem is they're explicitly funding a ton of people
who are engaging in electioneering, which is precisely the thing
they're not allowed to do. And so they put this language in to
try to restrict them to say, "Okay, well, they have to give this
permission because they're trying to prevent the people they're
paying from going to electioneering with their name attached
to any reasonable extent." But that's not like to me, you're
just actually trying to dodge campaign finance law, right? You're
explicitly paying electioners and saying, "Well, I don't want
to pay you to electioneer, so I'm going to put this clause in
that says you aren't allowed to do this." So either that clause
can actually functionally work and they can say you can't give
the speech you want to give you can't say what you want to give
thereby they control creators or that clause never kicks in thereby
I guess I it's just there to dodge campaign finance law in some
way. >> No it wouldn't be there to dodge just because you
pay somebody who participates in electioneering doesn't mean
that you're paying somebody to electioneer.
You could say that it might be like a sneaky way around it. You
could say >> are they paying anybody who doesn't
>> Um I don't know. I don't know every single content creator
that is under chorus. I haven't looked them all up. >> What
the does electioneer mean?
>> Basically promote candidates, endorse candidates, talk
about voting for specific parties, >> like advocating for
a person. Okay, >> Yeah, you I believe you can get out
the vote. I believe you could say like voting is important, but
I think if you endorse specific candidates, you you >> I
imagine that there's at least one
>> based on some of the content that I've seen some of
these people under Cororus do I imagine at least one of them
are
at least one of them based on what I've seen because I've seen
at least a couple of videos of the people who at least stated
that they were in the chorus program who are like the most lefty
whatever nonsense anti-elector people that Democrats are the
same as the Republicans voting
>> exam example I >> I don't like their name >> I
think I think you're basing that off of one you said you didn't
really look into this but two I think you're basing that off
of them being like free Palestine I don't think you are necessarily
anti-electoral because they're attacking the Democratic party
for for their position in Gaza. >> It's not off of exclusively
free Palestine.
It's that they're >> What was the other springboarded off?
It's that the Democrats are the same as the Republicans. There's
no difference. >> You saw one of them saying that? >> Yeah,
I saw a clip. I wish I had a name for you, but and we can drop
it unless I can go find the person with their name. But I remember
once this originally kicked off, there was just tons of creators
who were like just constantly going like, "Hey, here's a clip
of a creator that's super anti-democrat and like doesn't support
Democrats in really any way. Here's clips of uh creators who
are anti- uh Israel. Here's clips and it's just troves of clips."
>> I've not seen one of these people that doesn't support
the Democrats in any way. I'm I'm almost positive that didn't
>> Okay. Uh because obviously it's like their pitch acts
are about helping Democrats with messaging. Brian Tyler Cohen
when he was making this came on and talked to Destiny about exactly
what he wanted to do and it's all about helping the Democrats
in the DNC fill their digital gaps basically where they're like
completely incapable of reaching out to creators online. So uh
Chorus is nonpartisan is a new one. This is what Brian Tyler
Cohen had said in
Talk about conservative versus progressives on here. They're
literally sponsored by actually I believe they have a progressive
policy agenda that these people are supposed to adhere to. So
I I actually don't even know. I can't imagine they've hired anybody.
>> Progressive policy agenda. You
I believe progressive. Oh no, sorry. >> They're claiming
because they say progressive that that doesn't necessarily mean
Democrat or Republican. That's like >> I understand this
could say this, but right here it says the mood Democrats fume
over a weak early response to Trump. It's a war. Do Democrats
get that? What the [__] are Democrats doing? Democrats
wonder where their leaders are. This is what Chorus is supposed
to be solving. Is is basically the gap in digital messaging for
Democrats that he he said explicitly, this is the the same talking
point he uses so many times, okay? Is I think that the we've
all felt this where the Republicans feel like they just came
out of a morning meeting and they're like locked step on talking
points. We need that for the Democrats, too. That's why I'm starting
chorus. >> I remember this. Okay. And so the the prospect
of them being non-democrat aligned or nonpartisan or even non-political,
that's all fairly insane to me. It's like obviously not >> they're
obviously political. But what I'm saying is that there isn't
this unified message that I see really across the spectrum for
all of these people. Unless you want to make the argument that
like they're just not paying super close attention to the creators
they have in the program. Like there are some who are straight
up just on the Democrats for like Israel and Palestine. Um, and
then there's some who are giving them support over Israel and
Palestine. Like there's I I haven't noticed like really one unified
message
>> other than they hate Trump. >> Hold on. I think
Do you think that the Do you think that having one or two members
who think the Democrats are totally like biffing it on Israel
Palestine means that they're not Democrat aligned? >> No.
As I said literally five minutes ago when we talked about it
earlier, there is people that I recall seeing based on people
on my Twitter timeline posting not just, hey, the Democrats are
uh bad on Israel Palestine, but they're also like not really
better than Republicans.
>> So,
on Israel Palestine on one specific
>> in general. Okay. Um, I would love to see that one cuz
I feel like in general it's unlikely. But I think uh in general
as well that having like one or two people who seem to work against
the interest of the party, I don't know what is more Democrat
than that prospect.
That seems to be like the defining the defining characteristic
of the Democrats is they have like a big tent and they have people
who are standing outside of that tent who do represent them who
are Democratic members of Congress in some way, right? So, like
I I just don't understand this idea that like one or two people
it shows that they're like not they're not like Democrat aligned
or something. Um, >> no, I'm not saying that they're not
Democrat aligned. What I'm saying is this isn't like a clear
and obvious stipulation that would get you kicked out of the
program. >> If that was the case, even if it was one or
two, then that would still that would necessarily be the case
that if you say these things, you get kicked out of the program
would not be the >> I don't think there's uh I don't think
there's evidence of that either. the the idea that you can't
have a specific like uh policy position on Israel. I don't think
that's claimed in the article >> Um no, it's you keep going
back to Israel. I'm not using Israel as like the full like stop
benchmark outside of uh criticizing Democrats for it because
one thing I know for a fact is that
these people wor on Democrats for that specific. I know that
for a fact and I don't think that's contested. >> So what
is disproven? What what in the article is disproven because there's
somebody who said Democrats are equal to Republicans,
I guess, would be where I'm >> Oh, the idea that they have
to tow the party line in order to be able to continue making
money. >> So, I think that is basically claimed by the
by line, which I do not believe was written by Taylor, right,
to push the party line.
>> Um, unless
you believe that this sure, but this is a wired thing you'd have
to go at, right? month to put $8,000 a >> I mean, I could
go at both of them. If you're if you're putting your name on
an article that has a by line that you don't agree with, you
are consenting to it to a degree. >> But why would you
why would you be going after her when it's not her job to write
>> It's her responsibility to criticize that and potentially
say, "Hey, I'm not going to put my name on it." >> Like
1% her responsibility versus 99% Wired's responsibility.
No, I mean it depends on how much you care. Like based on the
by line, like if you if the by line massively goes against what
you're talking about, then you would probably stake a claim and
be like, "No, I don't agree with this." Also, I I can walk and
at the same time, I can criticize both of them. And I do. I would
obviously criticize Wired for anything that they have done during
this potentially or not potentially. Like I said, I haven't read
the whole thing,
>> a lot of people in chat are asking for the clip of the
person who said um Dems and Republicans. >> Yeah, I would
I literally have to I'd have to look back at it. Like I said,
I didn't look super closely at this. It just blew up all over
my feeds and I just there was tons of people like
uh all these other people who got clips of random people online.
>> Yeah, basically every single one of >> I can find
a clip. Yeah, basically every single one of those clips that
I've seen, they're essentially lying that it debunks something
in the article. Like it like blatantly, brazenly lying. From
what I've seen, Hutch is engaged in a lot of like just totally
disingenuous.
>> A lie that he said. >> Yeah. When when they say
that, oh, they disclosed that they were being paid by Chorus
when when that's the claim here that they weren't able to disclose
that they're being paid by Chorus or being paid by the program.
And and he his example is a bunch of influencers saying, in November,
I said I was partnering with Chorus. That is not a disclosure
that you're being paid by Chorus. You're being you're disclosing
before they even had the program where they could pay you. It's
an obvious lie to say that debunks the part of the article that's
that says the contracts prevent financial disclosures or standard
partnership disclosures, right? It's like actually anybody can
see that that you disclosing that you're partnered with this
thing, right? Like months and months and months before you're
being paid and and the the assertion is the artic in the article
is that you can't talk about being paid by this program, right?
that disclosing before the program ever existed is not dis is
not disproving the article in some way. I think that's obvious
to like anybody who looks at this. >> Wait,
hold on. Maybe I misunderstood you or maybe I misunderstand the
wording here. The contract reviewed by wires prohibits standard
partnership disclosures. Is this supposed to be exclusively about
the creator incubator >> It's about like # ad. Yes, it
is about it is about the creator incubator program. All of these
contracts are about the creator incubator program. >> Okay.
and there were no contingers
will not publicize their relationship with chorus or tell others
they are members members of the program without chorus's prior
consent.
>> So it says even that relationship will not publicize
their relationship with
So this is stating again
all they would need to do all anybody would need to do would
be to show a single person saying they were part of the incubator
program at all.
>> Uh in regards to this >> the claim from Wired
is about the >> Yes. And the contract for the disclosing
all they have to somebody disclosing after they get permission
is not disproving the claim about the contract. Right. So you
have a just a non-falsifiable claim without exposure of the contract.
>> Uh it's totally falsifiable by chorus or anybody who's
actually in charge of this. Do you think Wire's editorial staff
wants to lie? Do you think they want to be, you know, s like
successfully sued? >> No, I don't think that they necessarily
want to lie. Maybe they could have made a mistake. Maybe somebody
could have sent them uh, you know, a shoddy article or sorry,
a shoddy contract. I don't know. I I literally >> chorus
made a public statement as an organization saying that the contract
stipulations uh presented by Wired are >> I do I would
assume not. I don't know. >> So why do we think they're
lies? >> Why do we think it's >> I never said that
they're definitely lies. I I don't know why you keep >> You
said it's non falsifiable.
>> You said it's not falsifiable. >> That doesn't
mean that it's a lie. Wait, what does non-falsifiable mean? >> Means
prove otherwise. But it can be proven otherwise. Does that make
it a lie? Okay. So, I I don't You keep pushing things on to me
saying that I'm saying that I think you're shadow boxing demons
right now. >> What I'm saying it's not Hold on. What's
the implication that it's not
>> That they're making a claim that they that nobody can
disprove unless somebody discloses this random >> No, not
unless somebody discloses. It's that somebody can't that you
can't disprove. It could be disproven and it could be disproven
without disclosing the contract. >> I don't even think
that's true that it could be disproven through that if
without publishing the contract even without even if you publish
let's say chorus published a contract today that showed uh uh
you know that they didn't have these specific stipulations even
if they published that is that even proof because I would have
a guess that people who already buy this would just say something
to the effect of well this might not have been the contracts
that Wired has seen or anything like that because then at that
point it's a he said she said Wired's lying or Chorus is lying
Right. >> But I don't think Wired's working in antagonistic
fashion. I think they're like a journalistic outlet. I don't
believe they're working in some kind of
>> Of course they are. Like wait antagonistic in a sense
of like from >> they don't have a vendetta. Yeah. They
don't have a vendetta. They just want they want the truth out
there. That's like they're they're a long-standing
does does >> No. I I don't think I don't think Chorus has
any interest in putting the truth out because I think the truth
is is that a ton of this reporting is accurate and they don't
like the way it was uh they don't like that the fact that it
was >> and they are like upset about that. >> What
makes you say that? >> What makes you say
any of these things were lies? Well, because if any of these
things were lies, Chorus could have called up Wired. They could
have emailed Wired said, "Here's the contract provisions. We
think these are lies. here's where you are factually incorrect
about the the contracts we offered people and if you don't retract
this we will sue you which is the standard thing when when a
journalistic outlet is lying about you you say here's like the
facts
please retract this please correct this right but I've not seen
anything from that I've seen what I've seen rather than chorus
reaching out I've seen every creator who's aligned with chorus
attack Taylor Loren who is not even primarily responsible for
like the things that upset them about this article she is like
a secondary thing to why wouldn't she be the company you should
be attacking? Maybe I miss maybe I misunder may I'll fully admit
I'll take this.
Is she not the one who wrote the whole
>> Yes. But in every factual factual allegation in every
case of a factual allegation it says >> based on information
or contracts reviewed by wire they clearly brought in lawyers
they clearly like crossed their tees dotted their eyes on this
and they're saying we believe this is all accurate right there's
no restriction. >> Obviously it's under content. So you
so you believe every single person in chorus who's like potentially
seen these contracts, people who might have be in the in creator
incubator program, all these people are lying. >> I believe
they they like chorus. They like that >> David Pacman.
You believe Brian Tyler >> David Pacman when he says this
article is debunked, David Pacman is lying
>> No, no, no. I'm not saying when he says it's debunked.
I mean that he knows the truth that these were in the contracts
and he's just lying. >> I don't know that he knows the
exact contracts. I'm saying he is lying because he is saying
it's debunked with no evidence that it's debunked and not even
actually addressing the actual allegations made in the article.
>> dude, I've watched that guy say he doesn't know how
to pronounce Apac despite being apparently one of the only people
who knows that it's pronounced
>> It's pronounced IPAC. >> Yeah, but like only he
knows that. I don't know. >> Oh, you haven't seen those
tweets? >> No, I haven't. >> Okay, I'll I'll link
you. You guys keep going. Dave Pacman lies though. All right,
I'm gonna I'm gonna You can keep watching this. Keep going with
the video. I'm going to watch the David Pacman video and then
I'm going to see what his takeaway is and >> I'll let you
know if I see
>> if I agree that he's lying or if I agree with him or
something about it and
>> listen, we can go from there because point of contention,
>> right, I think is that somebody has to be lying here,
>> right? Um, yeah. I think so with David, I think he's
lying when he says it's debunked, which I don't know if he says
that in his videos. He definitely says it in a tweet. U, multiple
people have said this article is debunked and it is literally
not corrected. There's not a correction. There's not a uh like
a retraction. There's nothing like that. So, the article is not
debunked in my opinion. And my assertion is is that if these
allegations about the contracts were factually incorrect, Chorus
would reach out and if they weren't willing to retract this after
Chorus shows them what's in the contracts or of course like they
could also there could be a world where oh we had these in the
contracts and we found out right and we don't like that and we
updated them then I think in my opinion uh Harsh tour thank you
for the five gifted by the way thank you thank you awesome love
the support so I think
uh if they've not reached out there's no retraction I think wired
If if they were given new contracts or updated contracts and
they were explained a timeline, I think they would update the
article and say chorus realizing that creators felt this way
have updated their contracts and they're moving forward with
like without some of these provisions in there or they've they've
like highlighted these reasons, right? But I don't think it's
been like an education thing. I think it's been we're going to
attack Taylor Loren and we're going to say Taylor Lorenz is lying.
Taylor Loren lies about everything. She's totally like worthless
as a journalist. She's totally untrustworthy. This is absolutely
disgusting. And nobody's actually looked at the claims in the
article to say where they disagree or where they actually like
think things are wrong. And with the when the people have gone
and looked at the individual claims beyond the by line, beyond
like a little bit of the editorialization,
they've every time somebody says they're lies, it seems to me
like they're actually disingenuous. And they're the sad thing
is is they're smart people that I know are smart. They know the
things they're saying are false, but they are saying them anyway.
And it's very confusing. >> How do we know that they're
smart? Well,
>> so let let me just hear from you directly. What did
Chorus do wrong?
>> What did they do wrong? Their their creators initially
lashed out at Taylor and and basically came out and said things
that >> I'm talking about what sorry prior to the article
coming out and the purpose of the article. What is
chorus do wrong? >> Too many white men. >> Yeah,
if you want to damn it. Um, so in my opinion, what Kors did wrong
is they have contract provisions that seem to say that creators
shouldn't be disclosing this or they're they're trying to control
things that I don't think should be controlled uh by anybody
who's sponsoring something like this. Basically like preventing
disclosures of like the financial engagement that happened there.
Um, preventing discussions of of >> of particulars. And
I think when you put contract language like this in, people get
concerned. I think with with contracts, this is always how it
works. people aren't going to go right up to the line. They're
going to pull back from that line, right? So, you're told, "Oh,
don't do these disclosures." Most people are going to read that
and go, "Oh, I can't talk about this." Right? They're creating
that effect. And I think they could easily say, "Oh, you know what?
We're creating that effect. People are interpreting it that way.
Here's like some updated uh here's some updated language that
makes it clear how you can do this, right?" And I think in the
case of the disclosures, it seems like they did that. It seems
like it's better. And that was my first thing. I was like, "Oh,
if if they like responded and just said, here's like how you
can message." I would love to see that and see like how they
how they're talking about it. Right. So, it's some stuff about
the disclosures. I don't love that they're, you know, necessarily
trying to create like a like sort of a they're trying to take
advantage of creators doing um their own outreach and and trying
to get those contacts. I don't love it. I don't think it's awful.
Okay. And then I do think there's something here, and this is
just my personal opinion, that if you make somebody attend like
an hour and a half of mandated meetings where you're talking
about messaging and you're talking about policy, but it's from
a group with a specific interest, I think they're going to eventually
start leaning towards that. This is the general idea of lobbying,
right? You pay somebody, you give them uh updated information
from your side that's slanted for you. If you pay them and you
you actually try to educate them, that will work over time. That
will change their opinion over time. I think lobbying just does
work in general. Um, I mean, you could be you could be against
lobbying. So, my problem is based on what you said, it sounds
like you need to have like a pretty firm grasp of the law to
really kind of be against this, unless you're just making an
ethical argument. And if you're making an ethical argument >> the
disclosure stuff is an ethical argument for sure. >> Okay.
If you're making exclusively an ethical argument, then I would
say that I don't really care too much because in this context,
it would be not whether or not they're doing something ethical
or unethical. It's whether or not we're like doing something
that can benefit people and is within the legal the bounds of
legal system and whether or not we should be advocating for the
like campaign finance laws or laws surrounding this to be able
to change because the fact of the matter is that there's there's
like conservative groups that wait I would absolutely
but my abs hold on I'm let me finish with what I'm saying because
the reason why this I'm making the argument that I am is because
sure I would like maximum transparency from all like interactions
with politics and stuff like that that'd be great and stuff like
that however what we have is a if we're talking about the law
which this is kind of a a considerable part of it's whether or
not they have the ability to make these stipulations, whether
or not they have the ability. So, like I talked about prior where
they may not, they may be in legal trouble if these creators
go to events, go to charity places, do whatever, and then talk
about uh that they're here with Chorus, that they're doing this
x and y, and z with chorus. If you don't have a firm grasp of
campaign finance law and whether the line that you have to ride
before you're doing electioneering and stuff like that, then
I'm not sure how you could really have that ethical opinion because
I would agree with you. Everything should be transparent. But
if the law doesn't allow for that, then their hands are tied
and there's not really much that can be done. And as a just a
final thing towards the progressive victory thing, look at what
happened when we had something like progressive victory
where we people were following the rules and stuff like that,
right? Is you know all of our information is out there and half
of them just got doxed because in order to follow these rules,
our information needs to be public. >> You know that like
a very close associate of Dan Saltman was the first person to
publish those docs, right? that that's like basically how uh
KF became aware of that stuff and published a bunch of that.
>> Even if that were true, why would that change what I
just said?
>> Uh I would say that probably what Hassan was doing it's
it's like on the line, right? Um >> no, it's definitely
it's a very complicated thing. Um it's definitely >> Do
you think do you think going over public FC filings explicitly
in the context of talking about electioneering is wrong?
>> Yeah. while you're while you're attempting to bash the
people that you are bringing up the docks of. Yeah, absolutely.
100%. >> I think I I think I agree with you that if that's
like where the line is, right, that they are trying to like I
think bad is absolutely doxing there because he's bringing up
people's names and he is explicitly wanting to harass them, right?
So, I would agree with you 100%.
I think um it's it's a little closer on Hassan. I'd probably
lean towards you on Hassan where I I wouldn't like that video
to stay up. I don't know if I want Hassan to be banned. >> He
definitely should be banned. The idea that I can then just and
and Dan Saltman put out, I think, a fantastic response tweet
to this. >> Let's look at all of the Twitch employees who
made a political uh like any political contributions. We could
just look through their their stuff and then just sh on them
while we're just looking at their political
Have we got have we gotten we got Hannibal Vector's comment on
animal cruelty yet? I mean, I don't I don't care. I don't give
a who makes the comment. I think it's a good comment. I think
it makes sense. If this is what we're doing and we're just going,
you make political contributions and your information is in some
it is in some public registry. Therefore, I could just bring
it up on my stream and bash you, then let's take a look at Twitch.
Let's look take a look at everybody we disagree with. >> I
would I would agree with you, but it's it's downstream of something,
right? It's downstream of a legitimate discussion. No, as in
I don't think there was I don't I don't think there was a real
legitimate discussion. I mean, you could argue any political
disagreement is a legitimate discussion. The reason why I'm looking
at all of Twitch employees, every single Twitch employees political
contribution and looking at any docs information I can get on
them is because uh Twitch is uh like anti-Semitic and I want
to see what uh and criticize what these people are supporting
in their day-to-day lives. Oh, wow. Therefore, I have a legitimate
reason to go through every single last one of my stream. >> I
would I would argue that that could be in a public interest.
>> Um, you don't necessarily have to show the docs, right?
I would I would think showing you doc people like almost ever
it depends on what the information is, right? Like if it's their
if it's like, oh, I'm showing that this is a Twitch employee
and I'm showing the minimum element of this, right? As a Twitch
>> I don't think he was showing the minimum element. He
was showing what the zip code, the city, the full name of all
of these people. Like these weren't minim minimal elements >> which
is Yes. I think they I like like I said, Ben and Panata 100%
trying to do that. Um >> Well, no. And then Hassan having
it on his stream reading these things and then on the people.
>> I think I think it was like pretty to be honest with
you. Yeah. I I don't like it obviously, but I'm trying to say
this is downstream of just real quick. This is downstream of
a political concern about finance or like funding that is like
that is leading to his discussion of progressive victory which
he knows about which he thinks the funding was shady for and
then he goes into like a video that's about progressive uh victory
funding. Now the up thing is he goes to a video of somebody who's
known to dox people who's known to harass people and who's known
to just make things up and lie. Right? So I don't know like there's
some amount of culpability he has there for sure. Bad empanad's
video lied. I I pulled that video up. I I went through the lies
explicitly. I tried to keep the names out as much as I could,
but unfortunately Bannon Penati like yells them out at certain
points. Poor Xanderhal.
But I think a lot of those people actually do have their full
names known. I know some didn't. Like I know I totally I'm sympathetic
to, you know, not D not Dylan on the name, but Dylan on the like
location. I think he doesn't like his uh any of that stuff being
known. Um >> Well, sure. Yeah. But my point the whole like
connecting point even if we were to because it's a separate topic
about the doxing thing. Um the whole point is that you know they
might be trying to avoid a situation like that because that comes
with a whole bag of responsibilities and legal stuff. So the
legal concern has is intrinsic to the ethical concern because
we could agree that there should be maximal transparency around
political dealings and filings. But if the law says that hey
if you engage in political dealings or filings to x and y and
z level you have to do this that and this and that and this and
they don't want to do all of those various different things for
various legal reasons then their ethics are constrained right
I would love for the government to give everybody free food and
healthcare and stuff like that right ethically but I can't make
that legal tomorrow I have to deal with the legal system that
I exist within Sure, but they're not. Hold on. Just to be clear,
this is like if the government had all of this money, but for
some reason, this is like a little different, right? The the
laws are on the side, like the the ethics are on the side here
of saying you can't use this kind of financial structure to do
electioneering, but in my opinion, they are explicitly trying
to skirt that. They're explicitly trying to fund people who do
electioneering. They're explicitly trying to do that. And you
know that because they've set up a networking element that gets
networking information from politicians and policy experts, right,
and forwards it to them that they're collecting all of that.
And one of the primary stated goals of Brian Tyler Cohen and
even David Pacman to some extent is we didn't get Camala Harris
before the election. We need to get these Dems on these smaller
streams and actually creating like acolytes for them, right?
Creating like missionaries who who go Yeah, you legitimize this
channel. You create like somebody who is an an evangelist for
you now, right? They're explicitly trying to create contacts
between politicians and content creators. And I think if you're
if you're trying to say that that's not about electioneering
at all, right, while you pay a bunch of people who do some kind
of electioneering, right? I I think the idea that you don't engage
in electioneering is insane. And they're trying to put that in
there so they can prevent themselves from spending a certain
amount of money on electioneering. But it's like the explicit
goal is to do electioneering and to not have people report it
and not have to be concerned. I think they're explicitly trying
to break >> even in that you you recognize the key issue,
you know, which is that they can't spend x amount of money on
electioneering
um in in the given system. Even if I accept the idea that they're
trying to circumn
um how much money you can spend on electioneering and stuff,
that's just like laws on the books. That's not like an ethical
concern, especially in the context of the idea that Republicans
are almost certainly doing this and have been doing this. This
is not an ethical concern. The law is about the ethics. Yeah.
The law is really concern.
Hold on. Just to be clear, just to be clear, just to be clear,
if any of these people came out and said, "Uh, yeah, this is
a nuclear arms race and the Republicans have invented the hydrogen
bomb, which is this form of funding and we're we're matching
and you if that was the response from everybody, I'd respect
that." And I go, you know what? I understand it. But that's not
the response. The response is you're insane. You're lying about
this, right? >> Well, the creators sure can.
The creators are the one engaging in the sane response. Okay.
Hold on. Just sorry Jerry. I just have to get this out. If the
if the creators functionally cannot tell the truth, then them
for having any outrage here. Go yourself. If you can't tell me
the truth, what your actual position is, then go yourself and
stop trying to slander Taylor Loren for writing a factually accurate
article. >> Okay? So, uh I'm not saying they can't tell
the truth. What I'm saying is I don't think they're at liberty
to just say whatever they want about the intentions of the company
they work with. I think that is super bog standard for every
single company ever. I can't work at any company and then just
go, "Hey, the intentions of this company is X, Y, and Z." I can't
do that. That's not a thing you can do there. You can obviously
get fired for that. And I would say you obviously should be able
to be fired for that. This is this one want to bring up because
Taylor Lens is pretty been pretty like forthcoming with a lot
of information. Uh and she says that she she spoke to I think
more than one ethics
I don't know professor or something. I I wonder if she would
give the information on who she'd like to but Taylor Loren makes
it very clear that this is an article like outlining ethical
concerns. I I don't trust a single person that Taylor Lens considers
to be a authority on ethics. That woman
going to give you poisoned. >> No, I just think that she's
brain dead. So like anybody she considers to be an ethical authority
is probably brain dead if I had to guess. >> What What
makes her brain dead?
Because dude, the people that she aligns with and that she puts
on the timeline is
this half the claims that she makes is like when every time I
see this chick, every time I like her interactions with H3H3,
every single time that I see her interact with like on my timeline,
it's like her saying just really stupid [__] >> Well,
okay. I'd have to know what she say to H3H3.
>> They they had a whole back and forth. It's a whole thing
about uh H3 like her talking about like DMs that she sent to
Ela or and and like that and her misrepresenting those DMs and
then uh uh messaging Ethan is it's really she acts really weird
and then obviously her interactions with Hassan and just pure
glazing of Assan when she was like at this rally or whatever
and Assan was talking about uh in a positive into fashion talking
about like intimidating politicians with threats of violence
and she's just like, "Yeah, you know what? This it was pretty
good." Her video about um what is it? Uh what was it? Uh I I
forget what the title was, but it was essentially like uh Donald
Trump and like the people who were on Tik Tok or other social
media platforms like, "Hey, somebody should just do I think that's
what it was. Somebody should just do it." And stuff like that.
Uh somebody needs to do it. this piece that she put up. This
isn't an op-ed ad, right? This isn't like her opinionated
editorial work. This is like a investigative journalist uh article,
right? You would say that >> you're referring to me. I
there's a reason why I didn't bash her up till now, right? And
that that's because I couldn't take this as a work a piece of
work that stands on its own with Wired's, you know. Uh uh >> I'm
just asking because you said any expert that she talks to is
meaningless to you because >> any any person that she considers
to be an authority on ethics. Yeah. Because I think this woman's
Yeah. >> Well, I don't think she cites anybody, right?
I think she takes opinions from >> Yes. I'm what I'm saying.
Anybody she considers to be >> a authority worth listening
to on ethics, really mo most of anything, I would have deep questions
for. Yes. It's it's the same exact thing as like
>> she's even been taking like questions from smaller creators.
So, I think she might be forthcoming with who she reached out
to for
uh maybe influence or insight from. I'd be I'd be interested
in that. >> I'd be curious to um >> I thought you
like didn't care where the information came from. Really? Just
to be clear, you didn't care. >> I care about the validity
of the information. That's that's what I care about. Yeah. I
always do. Yeah. So like I think the I think basically I have
not seen a single retraction in this. The validity of the information
is quite >> No, no, no. Just because there isn't a retraction
doesn't mean the validity of the information is solid. You understand
that right? You those goalposts I feel like are ridiculous. And
just because there isn't a retraction >> or a correction
or correction. >> Yeah. That doesn't m that's not relevant
unless you believe that this wired is the beacon end all be all
all standard and if a truly unend
>> I I don't know how you are but me personally I kind
of like trust institutions a lot of the time because they've
like been invested with uh like our trust over time. So, organizations
like Wired, the New York Times, Politico, I'd like trust these
organizations to tell the truth and to to operate with journalistic
ethics until shown otherwise. Right. >> No, I'm just going
to look at the actual stuff. That's all I'm going to do. I'm
I'm going to look at the actual facts. And so, I would look at
um any of the information provided. Like I said before, you put
your weight behind the idea that you haven't seen a single instance
of any human being on Earth saying that they were a part of the
incubator uh program prior to this article. um
look at >> and I couldn't recall one saying that they were
being paid but there might be one or two but regardless the the
uh the claim in the article is that there's contract uh stipulations
saying they couldn't without express consent. So if those people
got it from that makes sense. Does that not make sense? >> Well,
sorry. You're making a different You're making a different argument,
right? I'm saying
that you said that you did not know of a single person who did
it prior. >> But that doesn't make the article incorrect.
If you if you showed me somebody who did, it doesn't make the
article incorrect. So, so your argument is that the only way
for the argu uh the article to be incorrect is if
uh Brian Tyra Cohen or Chorus publishes the cont publishes the
contract or >> if they just say this is or if Brian Tyler
Cohen or Chorus comes out and says actually the contract stipulations
they're describing don't exist and they are lying. >> Okay,
so if they say that they are not telling the truth, >> then
I'll put that into contention, right? if if they want to say
actually Wired is lying and these these contracts are fabricated
or like this is not something we've done right if they come out
and they say they're lying then I would totally be like oh I
need to withhold judgment now but in my opinion because they've
very explicitly not done that days over days and days now they've
not done that I can't sit here and be like oh well I think I
think Wired's lying still I'm like no obviously Chorus is lying
or they would have said Wired's lying they they're obviously
aware of it everybody in >> I'm going to watch the David
the David Pacman thing for for lies now. I'm going to be right
back.
>> Well, hold on. Do you want to Wait, Riley. Do you want
to like look into this a little bit more and I could do the Taylor
Loren thing and then after that I could uh we chat. Do you want
to do that? >> You could do that. Yeah, sure. >> Um
do you I don't know if you what time you got later today, but
uh like I'd do it later today or tomorrow. I just want I want
to go through this. I don't want to like argue, you know what
I mean? I want to do the >> I understand. I understand.
>> Yeah. Yeah. U I'll do the segment chat about it for
sure. >> Yeah. I but I want to talk about it like ASAP
because I do want to talk to people. I think I'm going to talk
to Lonerbox about this as well. >> So uh Okay. >> Yeah.
If uh I would love to talk more about it once you >> look
into it a little bit. >> Yeah. We'll we'll message we'll
message each other. I'm not I'm not worried about the timing.
>> Perfect. All right. >> Good luck. >> That
is such a crazy thing to accuse someone of. There is no basis
for that accusation. There's nothing that you can point to
to say this is why I think that it it it's completely
baseless and he is lying. He doesn't actually believe this. He's
just lying. Um >> dollars that's more than >> Hold
on. We'll skip to some other part >> Okay. Yeah. >> They
have no viewership. Like there is no real justification for like
tapping into these dudes.
>> bro. I'm watching uh >> I'm watching Hutch like
totally soy out about Hassan saying that PV is just a slush fund
for Destiny's friends and saying there's no reason to believe
that. And then I'm flicking back to this log from Destiny from
March of this year where he says that like he's really mad that
everybody sort of like was a vulture about his allegations and
progressive victory paid out millions in wages to all of those
people and the whole thing only existed because of me on top
of a billion other things. I'm just like yeah kind of threw you
guys all under the bus. Like unfortunately it seems like he's
sort of I the entire statement's from top to bottom. I don't
think this is the truth to be clear, but I will say that Hassan
seems to be more or less like quoting what Desessie is saying.
The only the thing only existed because of me. I got all these
people these I got all these people these jobs and then they
all turned on me. I don't know. It's very funny to me that uh
that he's saying this. It's not true. Like I know um I know that
one it didn't pay out millions. Yes. I think I think the whole
funding for progressive victory in the 2024 cycle was like $500,000.
I I don't know how much it was, but if uh millions were being
paid out, I gota I got to talk to uh my lawyer about
>> getting some some uh back pay on that >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Um but yeah, so what was your uh take
on the chorus situation? Like what was your take on the after
watching the Destiny Taylor Loren?
I think that
uh Taylor
knew my talking points, so she totally owned Destiny completely.
I just think I think um Wired put their reputation on the line
with this. If I think the next step of this is going to be it
would play out exactly like the Fox News Dominion case where
if if Wired is lying, the next step is to for Chorus to make
an official statement saying this is you are lying. You are lieling
us. These are factually incorrect claims. Here's our evidence
for it. and if you don't retract, we will be suing >> Okay.
Um,
so I saw two different responses
to
the the um the claims made in the Wired article
uh that I thought were rather interesting. But uh one thing I
guess I just wanted to
say was the uh
where did you see that David Pacman said that uh the article
was totally
>> Twitter. who's on Twitter. I looked at his Twitter.
I couldn't find it. Maybe I'm just
um I'll take your word for it. Uh
but so I one of the responses I saw was >> I'll just pull
it up for you really quickly. We just do this one real quick.
After a recent Wired hit piece, now fully debunked, false claims
started circulating. Sadly, some people chose to unsubscribe
from my website membership, Substack, or unfollowed on YouTube.
>> Okay. I don't know how I missed that. I went down David
Pacman's Twitter and I'm like really I guess I just missed that.
>> He might tweet a lot. It's August 29th if he tweets
like 10. >> No, I don't think he does. Maybe I was just
I I I remember being kind of surp Either way, it doesn't really
matter. >> yeah, sure. >> Um yeah, I was just curious
where because I didn't see it in the two videos, so I didn't
even frankly know he tweeted almost at all. But, uh,
okay. So, so this this kind of stems into my
kind of thesis, I guess, for how I viewed the article in context
is
I'm not sure
how different this contract is than many like in reality like
how how bad this contract or unethical or whatever this contract
would even really be. Because when we look at the wording and
and I think you might have looked at somebody responding to this
some 10-minute video that somebody did. >> Yeah. The >> I'm
kind of going over it. >> The alley video. Yeah. >> Yeah.
That that one. What was your response to that? >> Um with
regards to I I think it validates the reporting. Do you think
it validates the I mean, wait, in that 10-minute video, she speaks
on every critical point that the reporting made and gave real
tangible reasons for why this was potentially worded the way
it was in the contract.
>> Sure. Well, we can just uh we can go through it. I've
watched it a couple times. Oh god, why did this
>> Hello, I am >> this is our this is our video,
right? >> Yeah. leftist that is known for being very critical
of the Democratic Party. And I'm a member of a training program
called Chorus that teaches political content creators on the
left how to grow their platforms and make content creation into
a full-time job. I have a slew of receipts to explain why a very
fear-mongering article that came out yesterday about how this
program works is just very like inaccurate. And I think I'm a
good person to talk about this cuz I've seen a lot of people
afraid that this program is just a way for Democrats to pay people
off to blindly defend Democrats on the internet. And I understand
the fear because that would be diabolical if it was true. Um,
but this is a video of me like yelling at the DNC literally yesterday
over their refusal to endorse an arms embargo against Israel.
I am not one to hold back on criticizing the Democratic establishment.
So, I think I'm useful proof that that's not what this program
is about. I do feel there's
>> Yeah. So, I don't think that the program ever I don't
think it's an allegation that like everybody who is involved
in the program is doing this. I don't think I think the by line
is a little
>> I mean, the by line states that, right? The by line
says they're being paid to push party propaganda or something.
Push the party line. Now, I would say this goes to a couple different
pieces of information. One, David Pacman, sorry, no, not Brian
Tyler Cohen explicitly stating that this is their mission. Okay,
Republicans are Don't you hate it? He goes on Desi stream. He
goes on his own uh his own YouTube and says, "Don't you guys
hate it how it sometimes seems like Republicans when there's
a big news happening, it's like they they're lock step. They
went to a morning meeting. They're they've all got the same talking
points, right? Democrats need to be able to do the same and I'm
starting Chorus Media Group to make it happen. Okay. So, that's
a stated intent that I think is important. Um, I believe the
pitch deck for the company actually states that Democrats are
failing in their messaging. They're disorganized. They're not
able to message through these smaller channels at all. Right?
They've they've talked about this and they have daily messaging
check-ins. They have a weekly 1-hour advocacy training which
is about learning about a policy from the perspective of the
like the the literally uh what is it the progressive agenda for
chorus which you would have to assume follows pretty closely
with whatever the agenda would be for the 1630 fund. Then they
also have on big news days they'll have rapid response meetings.
Okay, rapid response days where Brian Tyler Cohen schedules a
special meeting where he gives people the talking points for
that day. Um, so again, I think the all of these things put together,
they're all acknowledged. None of them are refuted.
That to me translates to it being factually
maybe it's not a fact that they're being paid to push the party
line, but I think I don't think that's a crazy editorialization.
I don't think that's way over the line. >> Well, what you
would need from there is that if they deviate from because you
don't even have the details of what the they're specifically
talking about. Based on what I saw, it seems like they are giving
you the information of the things that happened like of the day.
So, it's not like they're necessarily giving you talking points,
but that they're giving you a list of things that happened in
that day and the sources of the things that happened in that
day. >> Um, now I don't disagree with you that it's probably
uh
colored in a specific way that is beneficial to them. I don't
disagree with that. But what you would need from there is them
explicitly cutting people out for not
uh representing that material in the way that they want.
>> Because otherwise then they're not being paid money
to push the agenda.
>> Sure. So what if doing that would make you clearly partisan
and be counted as like uh be counted against you as a 501c4?
Wouldn't it be fine to to invite other people who you could just
pay and that you could continue to dump in massive amounts of
money to pay other creators? So, if it's like let's say hypothetically
it's like 80% people who were willing to just push the party
line, right? And then the only cost that they have to not pushing
those other people out is they just paid somebody who is like
90% aligned with you instead of 100%. And you just don't kick
them out. Do you think that cuts against the idea that you're
being paid to push the party line? That that broadly that is
the goal. I all I'm saying is that if you are if you're being
paid to push the party line, I think you need to illustrate that
when people deviate from pushing the party line, they don't get
>> Um, so I don't know about that. There there's a six-month
thing. I would just say that that's acceptable like loss of investment
that they just don't care,
>> Well, no, no, no. Because you would need to illustrate
that these people are losing funding, right? That's what being
paid to push the party line means. If I'm getting paid to push
the party line, but they don't care if I don't push the party
line and I can still get paid that I'm not getting >> then
where are you getting the allegation that I'm getting paid to
push the party line?
>> So, how could we explain this? Um, it's it might not
be that every do you think what if they paid how do I explain
this? You can do this through soft power instead of hard power,
right? You don't have to directly cut people off who don't do
this. You can find people who are likely to do this. You can
amplify them. you can give them money so they can make content
full-time. And then if you miss on, let's say 5% of them or 10%
of them, you don't have to keep paying them. You could just say
it's a six-month program. You don't you don't come back, right?
You could you could just filter them out without ever actually
kicking them out. I don't think a requirement of pushing the
party line is kicking people out the second they cut against
the party. I think that would be that would obviously make them
partisan. That would make them immediately partisan and that
would get their their like massive FC fines and possibly like
reports against them. If your argument is that they're then I
would say that this is a massive editorializing.
If your argument isn't that they're being paid money to push
the party line, but instead they pick people who already push
a line that they agree with, then that is a massive editorializing.
They're not being paid money to push the line. They're being
paid money because they already make content that they find to
be good. >> So if I find somebody who loves driving and
I hire them as my driver, I'm a rich guy with a limousine. They
love driving. You think it would be an editorialization to say,
"I'm paying that person to drive me around." They'd just be driving
around in their own car if they weren't. >> No. If they
drive you around, then it is factually true that you are paying
them money to drive you around.
>> It is not factually true that these people are being
paid money to to push the party line. It hasn't been proven.
It hasn't been substantiated.
>> What if I would say that it is a clear push against
if your argument is that they're finding people who push a the
party line in a way that they approve
um and
already prior to signing them onto this program and then they
sign them on to the program and then if they miss with some of
these people or or whatever then after a long period or after
their contract is naturally up then they stop paying them to
uh to be a part of their program then
uh I I mean one I would need to see that as a fact and number
two like I don't see how they're being paid necessarily to push
the party fine. They're being paid.
>> They're just being they you could say that you could
apply motive there, but you need more than that just because
these people are all happen to be paid. Even if it's 100%. Well,
just because all these people are happen to be paid who push
the party line, you need to substantiate that that is the reason
why they're being paid.
>> Well, I would say if they were going to push the party
line anyway and you pay them to do that, you know, five times
more than they would have otherwise, I would say that is paying
them to push the party line. But beyond that, right, um, beyond
that, I think it's the messaging talk. I think it's the stated
intent from Brian Tyer Cohen that he wants this to be about dem
me messaging, right? Hold on a second. Let's see here. My evil
Johnny Bravo's got a message here in the chat. This is established.
It's not an esoteric concept. There are laws that fell into place
with the FTC to prevent record companies from using bribes to
promote artists to radio DJs. You pay in advance without expectation,
but an implied understanding is developed in the industry. Okay.
So,
uh, what are you trying to say? That if you don't play their
artist, they won't keep paying. Oh, so like they they start paying
and it's not for for you to like play their artists. Poliola.
Okay. This is what pola is. Okay. That you pay people and there's
like an understanding there, but it can't be explicit because
it's against the law to be explicit.
And then, okay. And then you It's basically like you form the
understanding. Yeah. So, I would say this this seems to me like
a pretty obvious
concept, but like I don't even think there's an >> applied
for such a party established paper to put up like they're being
paid money to push the party line, you're going to need a lot
more to go off of than that. In my opinion, I think you need
a lot more to go off of.
>> That's a crazy thing to say for like a reputable paper.
>> Uh I think it's an editorialization. I think it's a
little hyperbolic. I don't think it's insanely hyperbolic. And
I think the the reporting in there, I don't feel like it's like
a crazy crazy claim. And I I especially don't think that it's
disproven by showing that one person likes Palestine. I think
that's insane. Out of 85 to 90 people in that cohort, showing
one of them likes Palestine. I don't think that disproves the
idea that they could be getting paid >> No, I I don't think
it is that there's only one. No, there's several. No. >> Uh
there's at least two that I've seen. >> Okay. There's definitely
not more than four or five and out of like 80 something, right?
>> Oh, sorry. There's not more than four or five. I didn't
down each and every one of them, but >> there's Yeah, there's
not more than four or five that are public, but I would say that
it could be that they actually are even more pro Palestine than
the Democratic party. Like significantly so, right? They're getting
a lot of Tik Tok influencers. They might be like way more progressive
on Palestine on Israel Palestine than the Democratic Party. That
could be true. I'd say on the rest of the issues, they're probably
close to in lock step in my opinion.
>> Yeah, that could be true. >> Um, but regardless,
I just don't I I think this is, by the way, this would be the
worst part of the article to me is the title and by line. So,
I am I'm like defending it a little bit, but I do think it's
the worst part of the article. I think it's over editorialized.
I think it's misleading, but I don't think it's like insane.
I don't think it's like >> I think it's massively misleading,
to be honest. I I and I think it colors the rest of the article.
the the the entire and I think this is because I remember when
we had talked about it you said that there was a lot of people
who are saying that this article is debunked and stuff like that
and you said that it doesn't critique the main uh argument of
the article uh being the main argument as I understand your perspective
to be that there was the incubator uh creator incubator program
which had specific stipulations inside of the contract to keep
it uh or to try and uh prevent disclosures and uh not be transparent
with how much money they're getting paid. But I I I personally
believe that that isn't the crux of this whole article. The crux
of this whole article is exactly what the title says and the
by line says. It's that this group is secretly funding Democrat
influencers to be able to tow the party line. And if you look
at every single person, I would say this is substantiated by
every single person who has come away with some kind of conclusion
about this article, all of their conclusions are that these Democratic
these dem Dem influencers are being pushed in a very specific
direction with their content to be able to make very specific
content that uh is is likeing the party line. It's not that specifically
the incubator program was had a specific contract stipulation
that wasn't as transparent as we would like it to be. >> So
do you think it's Taylor Lorenz's fault that
Wired put this title and by line in here that are not >> I
think it is both of their faults. Yeah, I think it's both of
their faults. I I think she should have stood on it and been
like, "Yeah, I don't think that you should do this." And I also
think the the substance of the article itself doesn't meet merit
with uh that being the the crux critique. It's most of the article
is going through and talking about yes some of the disclosure
but it's substantiating it as being like this crippling thing
that prevents people from talking about uh uh their their participation
in chorus and prevents them from disclosing stuff. And that's
kind of why I wanted you to watch this video because I'm curious
what your interpretation is of this >> I don't know sorry
that's crippling them from from disclosing can I get uh are you
talking about something in the article cuz like I think I think
the contract language isn't even disputed that they were prevented
from like that there is contract language saying you can't do
standard partnership disclosures don't do this right
>> um and I don't think
>> she doesn't dispute it either >> okay like she
doesn't dispute that that's the case. >> Yeah, she she
contextualizes it in the same way that I was referring to you
where I said, I don't think you can really have an ethical opinion
on this without having some kind of legal understanding or practical
understanding of the contract language. And it seems like she
contextualizes it in a way that I believe one that I was thinking
in a hypothetical sense could be the case and it seems like from
her articulation is the case. >> Well, I mean, we can hear
from her. Why do you think that Wired had a lawyer to look at
this and interpret it the way they did? >> Because I think
it can be interpreted in many different ways and it's very uh
it the contract can be uh predatory and it can be misused. But
what you really need to do is you need to look at the practical
application of the contract. >> Oh, because
she goes into it
>> like they're just starting. No, what I'm saying is that
this, and she goes into it, is that contracts like this, just
like contracts with every single corporation ever in since the
beginning of mankind, is made specifically to favor the business
to be able to pretty much sue you for whatever the they want.
Right? If you do anything that we don't like, we reserve the
right to sue your ass into oblivion. And that is kind of what
she's talking about is that the language inside of the the contract
allows for a wide breadth of latitude legally for chorus, but
in practicality, it's just like it's really lax in casual because
it's just trying to prevent people from
uh it's trying to cover their own ads legally. Why do you think
that out of the 80 creators there's only like 80 there's only
like five to maybe 10 tops that have disclosed that they're part
of the program? >> Uh I'm not I'm not even sure that's
true because isn't there like 10 creators on their website or
you're talking about the incubator. >> Hold on. We could
we Yeah, the incubator program obviously. Yeah. Sorry if my >> I
don't know I don't know how many uh a part of the incubator program
have disclosed it. I'll take your word for it that it's >> Well,
because the contract only applies to people in the incubator
program, right? The contract is for people in the incubator program.
>> No. And according to at least the chick that the video
is, I don't think she was a part of the incubator program cuz
she said, well, she might have been. She said she signed a similar
contract >> or and she uh or at least speaks about a similar
contract and that she uh I believe went on board in like November
of 2024 like during the original inception of the program >> joined
but I do not believe she joined as uh like as a so the program
didn't exist. They weren't doing this as far as I understand
program didn't exist. They weren't doing this financial aspect
but people joined as partners to try to get chorus off the ground.
They were crowdsourcing donations and stuff for them. Right.
Yeah. And so what and she speaks about it as if she signed on
to a similar contract and then contextualizes
>> Okay. Um she did sign one of these contracts and that's
why she pulls up her contract explicitly to show for one of the
sections and she is in the the program but she didn't disclose
that she was in the program before starting it. Right? So this
will be a big thing that comes up I believe as we go through
it. >> people in this cohort who chill a little bit too
hard for the Democrats but that's a them problem not a this program
problem. Without further ado, let's get into the claims of the
article versus my receipts. Okay, so the first like main big
scary thing that's written into this article. His creators told
Wire that the contract stipulated they'd be kicked out and essentially
cut off financially if they even so much as acknowledged that
they were part of the programmer that Chorus existed. No. Here's
a video of someone named Heidi who's in the cohort explaining
what Chorus is and that she's joining it on November 20th.
>> So this is like an objectively
response because the cohorts didn't exist, the program didn't
exist, the contracts didn't exist. You cannot disclose your financial
agreement or any contract that you've signed with these people
when those contracts don't exist, when the program doesn't exist,
when the funding doesn't exist.
>> You're talking if you're talking specifically about
the incubator program, then yeah, but I don't think this is an
objectively thing to say when talking about chorus as it exists
in its
>> is about the incubator program. The article is the contracts
in the article about the No, the article is all in reference
to the art the article is about principally the article is about
like a dark money group funding specifically this chorus program
and then like consistently flip-flops between chorus and the
people who are participating in the totality of chorus and not
explicitly the incubator
>> So the problem is written to be able to consolidate
exclusively for the incubator program. the incubator program
is the only thing being funded as far as I know by 16:30. >> Yeah.
So I I I don't I genuinely don't know about the rest of Chorus's
funding. But whether that's true or not, they don't make proper
distinctions inside of the article about uh Chorus as it exists
in its entirety versus the incubator program and often flip-flops
by talking about people who participated principally and the
the founding of Chorus and the development of Chorus even prior
to the incubator program. So I don't think this is a like point
for people to talk about chorus and more moreover I would say
that the people who
and agree with this article seems to have all come away with
the interpretation that chorus as an entity in it in it of its
in its entirety is doing these things right that like the >> the
Hassan not even just the Hassan types if you look up any
I don't know can I really blame so can I blame can I blame Taylor
Loren for propagandists intentionally misreading and and lying
about her. >> No, I don't believe it is an intentional
misreading. I think if you read this as an individual who isn't
explicitly like looking for like I I think if you do not read
this with an incredibly critical eye, you come away with the
interpretation that Chorus is a dark money group funded by uh
what is it? I I keep want to say Zero Dark 30, but you know what
I'm talking about. That group
>> me too. Oh, I kept thinking Zero Zero Dark 30. Oh, damn.
Let's go. I said that
>> I know. 1630. That's what I keep thinking too.
>> So, like that is the That's a funny bit there. I think
that is the way that most people are going to interpret reading
this article is that Chorus is a dark money group funded by 1630.
>> Well, they're technically I think they're also a 501c4.
They're 501 Are they a 501c4 taking money from a 501c4?
Chorus Media Group is I believe a 501c4.
Um, I I thought it was funny that they they talk about where
they're funded from, okay, in their frequently asked questions.
Who funds Chorus? Well, Chorus is just a little grassroots thing.
Support from over 5,000 individuals since launching in December
I think I think this is just them not updating their website.
But, um,
I think it's I think it's pretty funny that they they don't say
this, >> but that they don't disclose that 1630 is funding
them.
>> I think it's funny. Uh anyway, um so like from the very
beginning, the context of this article provided at the very beginning
is in a private group chat in June, dozens of Democratic political
influencers discussed whether to take advantage of an enticing
opportunity. They're being offered $8,000 in June per month to
take part in a secretive program aimed at bolstering Democratic
messaging on the internet.
I do not think this is even remotely over anything. I think this
is just accurate that this program is aimed at bolstering democratic
messaging on the internet. It is they're being offered up to
$8,000 per month and it started in June. I this is just like
all accurate. >> The thing I would contest here is that
it's a secretive program. >> Uh so you couldn't talk about
the program and none of these people disclose the program starting.
>> There's not as far as I know. Where do you get if I
could find a single financial disclosure? if I could f us from
the contracts and I've not seen anybody dispute that you're not
supposed to talk about the contracts or who who pays for it explicitly
that that seems >> So even in this article I there is like
contradictions to that because we talk about the uh without prior
approval and we talked about without prior approval and how that
would work. I think the chicken side of the video gives a lackluster
explanation that sounds like it's not probably not the case and
if I had to guess it was probably more of a legal thing. But
also um we talk about like uh public disclosures in this article
it states that uh a lawyer from
uh chorus reached out and spoke specifically about how to address
uh the affiliation with the program publicly. So you were able
to talk about it publicly? No. >> Uh so they were allowed
to disclose chorus publicly. It does not say they were allowed
to talk about the program publicly from what I've seen here.
So >> So then why did they add that then? >> Uh because
your claim is that the princip it was so obvious that they were
talking specifically about the program and not chorus publicly.
Then why would they post this
>> They're not allowed to talk about the program. And the
update from Graeme Wilson, the lawyer says it's an update. Uh
the update from Graeme Wilson the lawyer says that they they
had a slide that offers several talking points if a member of
the cohort wanted to discuss chorus publicly. This does not say
the the creator incubator program. It says chorus publicly. It
continues
not just real quick. I just want to point out so obvious they're
talking about the >> uh because this was an update shared
from them and I think they just didn't want to not throw that
update in because this guy is basically saying I have an update
for you. Here's how they're allowed to talk about it. But they're
alleging that you're not allowed to talk talk about the program.
They were given an update that says you're not allowed to talk
about chorus or sorry that you're allowed to talk about chorus
in general publicly. >> Well, according to you that's this
article has nothing to do with whether or not you can talk about
chorus. So, I think I think they're trying to not keep I think
they're trying to be they they know they're being accused of
like uh this article being like defaming and I think they're
including the update to to satisfy chorus to show that they're
willing to take updates and to try to not have this company like
continue to slander them, right? I think they they added that
update. I don't think the update makes sense and they don't change.
They also forbid creators from disclosing the identity of any
funer and give course the ability to remove all this. Hold on.
Contracts reviewed by Wire prohibits standard partnership disclosures
declaring that the creators will not publicize their relationship
with Chorus or tell others that they're members of the program
without Chorus' prior consent. So this part not publicize their
relationship they're saying, "Oh, we actually did talk about."
So that is the update we did actually say here are a couple ways
that offers several talking points if a member wants to discuss
the cohort or other cohort. >> Wouldn't that imply? So
you're you're saying that right there to not publicize their
relationship with Chorus. Is that not a thing that a reasonable
reader could read and think that they're talking about all of
Chorus and not that they're talking about a very specific program
in Chorus that happened a second >> Yeah. Yeah. It sounds
like there's language in the contract that says not to publicize
your relationship with Chorus. Now, a lot of the creators in
this wouldn't have had a previous relationship with Chorus. I'm
guessing there are ways that the existing creators uh who already
had announced a partnership with this would have talked about
it. And I'm guessing that's why they had to clarify things, right?
>> So, prior to this program, many of these creators had
said, "I'm working with Chorus. I'm helping them." >> That's
my question. >> That basically it's they're alleging that
the article says people who signed this contract can't talk about
Chorus. But there are people who before this had partnered with
Chorus and talked about partnerships with Chorus, but not people
on the program. I've not seen a single person who's on this program
who has come out and said uh with sorry without um before this
article was made, oh I'm getting money from this chorus thing.
>> But that doesn't have to be the case.
But either way, my my that that doesn't address my point. My
point is that a reasonable reader would read that section talking
about not declaring uh not being able to publicize the relationship
with Chorus and believe it explicitly pertains to chorus and
not explicitly just this one program. Sorry, this is this is
saying chorus. This is saying chorus. >> Yes, this is saying
the people who sign this amongst many other statements inside
of the the
article would have a reasonable reader believe that chorus as
its entirety is like some dark money group that is some secretive
shadowy >> That would not make any sense because there's
lots of public announcements about chorus but that wouldn't make
any sense. So I this this is about the people signing the contract
for the incubator program are being told you shouldn't discuss
your you shouldn't publicize your relationship with chorus. That
is being said. >> Um so then so then this is now kind of
why I want to or where I would like to go back to the Tik Tok
video because I think she explains it in a way that I was kind
of trying to contextualize it that I think kind of makes sense
and I want to hear your response.
But I will say that talking about so this is not dispositive
of anything. This is basically saying um
this is somebody saying that
you know in in June they changed the speed limit on that thing
to 60 mph from 50 mph
and they're going look here's me driving like uh
here's me driving you know 65 back before that and I didn't even
get pulled over. I'm not I'm actually [__] the analogy.
I had it earlier, but I'm I'm like actually borderline falling
asleep. I I'll figure it out another time. This is not actually
substantially like dealing with this at all. This is before they
had the the program, before they had the incubator program. Um
the the point of the article is the incubator program contracts
are preventing disclosures or have language that that claims
you should not disclose. Right. >> Sure. Let's let's keep
watching
how they address the language. >> Yeah. I would just say
any any disclosures that happened before this program existed
or before any of them were signed up for it, right before they
were getting the money and signing those contracts, they're worthless
to me. >> Here is the chorus website that is public facing.
Anyone can see it uh with literal pictures of creators that are
in the cohort. In the contract I signed, there is some language
that says, "Hey, please like before you make a public statement
about what Chorus is, just check with us." The reason for that
is that as the article states, there's over 90 influencers in
the program, many of whom have very small accounts and joined
the program to get like mentorship and happen to be immigrants
or trans in a red state, right? And like already happen to be
kind of in extra danger right now. And so >> so they they
can't disclose because they're trans people in a red state and
they might get like attacked by >> Yeah. I don't I don't
think there's a good argument for not disclosing. I don't I don't
think there's a good argument. Uh I Not even sure how this would
specifically work, but yeah, just uh you can keep going. >> I
think this is like horrible cope from Tik Tok creators who are
used to using identity politics to just like bully like crybully
their way into being like not criticized. I I think it's just
like part for the course with anybody who's operates in this.
>> Though the goal with the like please check with us clause
was to make sure that small creators who already had targets
on their back weren't accidentally like featured on a huge page
and then suddenly had an onslaught of threats from the right.
Orus has never been kept some nefarious secret, right? People
have been talking about it. It was more just, hey, this is already
an unsafe job for some people. Check with us in advance so you
don't accidentally like add to someone's unsafety. Okay. Number
>> Yeah, that's uh total and like I I've never heard that's
insane. >> So, just to be clear, you think this person
is
>> uh I think they are just making something up because
they're sleeping for the people paying them $8,000 a month reflexively
as most people would understand. What I'm saying is it's one
thing to say because we both agree that this is a point, but
that the idea is whether or not they had the ability to disclose
and all they had to do was come forward about it. And maybe the
reason that they were given or the reason that they had interpreted
was but the question is whether or not they believed that they
had the ability to come forward and then disclose whether or
not they were a part of um a chorus or or a part of the program.
Right. >> I think it's both. I think it's the contract
language and what their belief was. What a reasonable person
would believe based on the contract. What the what the individuals
who came forward and were whistleblowing essentially thought
it meant. Right? I think they include all of these things and
I think if they only had one of those >> this person believe
that they could unless do you believe that they're lying >> it's
clear that this person had a special relationship with chorus
where they were involved in this cohort way before it was involved
way before it was um created. Sorry they were involved with this
reason you have no reason to believe that this uh contract stipulation
is any different for them than it is anybody else. >> Uh
I could see it being different. I could see it being different
because she's already disclosed a partnership with Chorus. So,
if she signs a contract that says I'm not going to disclose it
further, I that could be like weird. It's possible she has something
slightly different. She's in the the accelerator or whatever
cohort. She's in the $8,000 a month tier of the cohort. So, um
>> So, she's in the incubator program. >> Yeah, she's
in the incubator program. Yeah, she talk she posts like a lot
more stuff about it as well. I'm guessing she asked for explicit
permission to talk about all of this and
like I feel like probably talked through how she was going to
make this video with them, but you know that's that's me. This
conspiracy I don't have any proof of that. I would imagine she
talked through >> but we have we have no reason to believe
that she's lying about how she feels like she could disclose
it at any time. Right. We have no reason to believe that she's
lying. >> Okay. Do you wait has anybody asked her if she
got consent from Chorus before disclosing it? >> I'm assuming
that there's somebody who asked her. I don't know if she >> Um
because I I would love to know that cuz then I would assume that
if she asked permission, then that's knowing that she couldn't
disclose it without permission, which is what the contract
>> No, I'm not disputing that you have to with permission.
You you could only disclose it with permission. The thing that
I'm disputing is whether or not the permission is readily available
to pretty much anybody who wants to disclose. That's the that's
the the the difference, right? >> Uh sure you you could
say that, but I would say most people might think that there's
some bad reason to disclose and they might never ever seek that
permission, right? Like I I think that's the default with a lot
of contracts that if you say you need my permission to do this,
that's normally a thing that is uh difficult. Now, it's not always
the case, and maybe she's just the only go-getter who is thinking
about this, right? Uh, in that case, I would just say statements
from court saying, "We we do this automatically. It's like only
here as a legal thing. Actually, we don't really think it's that
important." You know, I I would say to me, if that was the highlight
here where they respond and they say, "Well, actually, here's
like a reason we do it and I understand it looks bad, but this
is like more or less what we're trying to do, what we're trying
to accomplish, and it's just a misunderstanding." That would
make total sense to me when they come out and say that this is
a total hit and Taylor Lorenz is lying and also she loves Tucker
Carlson and uh and Candace Owens actually I think when you go
with that creators who are part of this program who are saying
that you are able to disclose these things you just need to ask
for permission and you have these meetings where there are slides
being shown albeit I'll I'll just grant the idea that it's only
talking about chorus and not the incubator program and it doesn't
explicitly state the incubator program. You have these slides
that talk about how uh you can talk about the chorus program
publicly. Then at what point am I going to be like, "Hey, maybe
some of the people who thought that there was no imaginable way
that they could have disclosed this publicly that these people
might be might have uh uh kind of gotten it wrong, kind of misunderstood
what it was
>> Okay. Um, I just want to point out one more time that
she is her her primary argument for that was that they were trying
to protect trans creators in red states essentially like the
the total cope one. So whatever like she's on she's like totally
um and well that it doesn't matter. So my point is it doesn't
matter if her reasoning for why she believed she was at liberty
to request
uh or or that she needed permission to talk about it publicly.
That isn't that's not material. What's material is her ready
her ability to get that permission uh granted upon request which
she seems to be making the argument that she would have been
granted permission pretty much upon request. So, I would just
say if it's readily available, I'm not totally sure why the need
for the contract language exists.
>> She gets into it, which is exactly what I had brought
up when I had originally came on and I was talking about legal
ease stuff. So, I think we should probably keep moving on with
the video. >> According to copies of the contract view
by Wired, creators in the program must funnel all bookings with
lawmakers and political leaders through chorus. No, again, I
literally have the contract. >> So, uh this one I think
is just totally proven by the actual contract, right? >> Totally
proven. What do you mean?
stuff is totally proven. >> So this is all all contacts
with politicians with like politicians and policy experts that
are related to Chorus's thing need to be funneled through the
Chorus newsroom. >> They need to be like expressed there
in some way. There needs to be an artifact that Chorus can track
and add that contact to their own. I think that's expressly stated
here. I think it's expressly stated in the article. I don't see
a lot of issue with it. >> Um I didn't really care much
for this claim. So uh let me just read it. Chorus will provide
contracts with uh access to chorus newsroom which coordinates
booking engagement opportunities for creators with government
officials, policy, nonprofits and others who ex uh who
expertise
and experience whose expertise and experience are relevant to
chorus's progressive policy agenda. contractor agrees to utilize
the chorus newsroom to uh to book engagements, disclose to the
chorus newsroom room personnel uh any engagements with government
officials or others on topics related to Chorus's policy agenda
that contractor arranges through uh other means and I can't read
the rest of it. >> Um collaborates with Chorus uh regarding
all such separately
um arranged engagements or whatever. So basically um you need
to disclose to the course newsroom. I believe chorus newsroom
is software. It's basically like customer relationship management.
So you you make like contacts for the people you're talking to
maybe do a booking to show when you scheduled with them. So it
should be filed through there right they should be updated on
it. And then it says collaborate fully regarding all such separate.
So I don't know if that means you need to check in with them.
Collaborate is a little confusing right? Collaborate mean could
mean you have to check in with them. It could mean
um I don't know, you ask for like questions you should ask them.
I have no idea what it means, right? Could mean I I haven't seen
that addressed by anyone. What collaborate fully means. >> Um
yeah, I mean I I don't know what collaborate fully would mean
either, but uh just uh
I I'm curious what your interpretation of how she's going to
talk about it is. >> Oh, I think she basically said that
from the article. So the claim from the >> Okay. Number
two, according to copies of the contract viewed by Wired, creators
in the program must funnel all bookings with lawmakers and political
leaders through Chorus. No, again, I literally have the contract
right here. I'll talk through it in >> and I I believe
that this is essentially >> Yeah, sorry. Just just push
play and then have her >> minute. But first, let me show
you this. Here's an email of me directly reaching out to the
Zuron campaign to try to interview him cuz Chorus does not control
who I interview or what I post. I also sometimes text the comm's
directors directly of like Congress people that I want to interview
because usually the congressional offices will give out these
little business cards. And this is not like specific to content
creators. This is just like if you go to try to talk to your
senator, their people will give you little business cards. I
blurt out the name of the specific person cuz I feel awkward,
but like anybody can get these business cards and then you can
just text them. Chorus does not control that. I've done lots
of congressional interviews and usually I just set them up myself.
Here's the section of the contract, right, that confirms that.
It says they want you to disclose to Chorus any engagement with
government officials related to course's policy agenda. >> Collaborate
fully with Chorus. are also separately engaged engagements, arranged
engagements. Sorry. So I I think she just doesn't follow the
contract at all and they don't bother her. That contractor, that's
me, I'm the contractor, arranges through other means, right?
So if I just arrange it myself with a congress person, I just
let chorus know so that they know that congress person's open
to booking and other people in chorus can do it, too. Accidentally,
I always forget to let chorus know. Like I don't think I've ever
told them that before, but that's >> So I think I think
she's basically saying I just don't follow the contract, which
is kind of funny. Um cuz it is explicitly stating you're agreeing
to do all of these things. She's basically just saying I don't
follow at all. So, this is kind of the overarching point that
I was making and that she's going to further extrapolate on,
which is that it's it's the ex it is the industry standard in
every single face of the planet Earth as I know it and probably
forever will be into perpetuity, which is when businesses set
up contracts for you to sign, they just give themselves as much
power as legally possible over everything that you do in the
hopes that if they ever don't like anything that you do that
they are in the best advantageous position as possible. So her
point is that that the contract language does it it stipulates
these various things but in practicality you can just book with
these people and just be like yo I'm hitting up the Zeron next
week and they be like let them know and then that's it >> which
is kind of insane.
>> She's saying she doesn't care. Although I could actually
go back and look at the policy for us.
>> She have an email where she showed it >> she showed
an email. showed an email >> June 2nd. So, I don't know.
This could be before June 2nd, depending on when she joined the
cohort or signed it. It could be before she even signed a contract
saying she would do that, >> right? So, this might not
actually be disproving any. >> I think the point of this
video is I mean, she said that she signed a contract with the
some of the stipulations. I believe she goes on to say every
one of the stipulations that is laid out in the wired article.
So, she isn't even debating the specific
things in the article as being uh uh like like necessarily untrue,
but inaccurate relative to how it actually works in the contract.
>> I'm being told this is actually before the So, she's
giving proof that's from before the contract. She's saying, "I
did this and I didn't let anybody know." >> No, she's saying
that she signed a contract and pretty much the same. That's my
it's it doesn't matter if she This is before the cohort program
because according to her, she signed a contract that has all
of the principal stipulations that are at issue in the the cohort
uh in in the wired article. >> You believe that she signed
a contract from them before any of this that has all the same
stipulations that is like >> she's alleging that? Yeah,
she she alleges that she was able to do that or she did that.
But she does she allege that she signed it before like way before
like in April, in March, in
>> Um I'm not sure the exact month, but she alleges that
she's she signed a contract
>> explicitly. Uh >> but I know I know these things.
I know she's in,000 tier either. So then you would be admitting
or sorry, you would be um saying that this person is just directly
lying about it. as according because if that was the case, then
she would have to be knowingly talking about a contract that
she signed like a month ago and talk about events
>> to contradict the claims that that contract restricted
her with uh events from like several months ago. So you're saying
that this person is boldfaced >> That is what I think explicitly
almost all of these people are doing. Yes. >> Okay. I think
I think they've signed a contract after the fact >> to
go off.
So, I've not seen any of them, none of them disclosed when they
signed those contracts. None of them disclosed they're being
paid by Chorus, right, going up to this point. And nobody has
talked about them getting paid by Chorus from before this. So,
I would need to see that they were being paid not based on this.
She says she's a part of this program, this incubator program
specifically. This incubator program started in June. So, I there's
two days in June that it could have started. I don't know if
it started then cuz it's says a month ago in the Wired article
and that was published on August
whatever 26th or something 27th. So like I I feel like it's unlikely
she signed the exact cohort contract in June. >> Yeah.
I I just I don't believe I I don't think off rip that without
considerable information that we would believe because it's not
it's not like these people are misinterpreting it. Your argument
would have to be that they're making fullthroated bold-faced
malicious
>> So, you're saying that if she had if she signed the
contract that applied to this on like July 1st, let's say, and
she was showing an email from June 2nd and saying, "Look, I do
this. I do this myself, she's just maliciously lying, >> Yeah.
Because she would be using an argument about while literally
showing a contract that she signed a month later than when she
did the booking. Unless,
which would be, I think, far more reasonable, which is uh unless
she's making the argument that she's still able to operate in
a similar manner as what she did during this >> because
she signed the similar contract before or something, right? She
signed a similar contract in like March, let's >> She says
in this video, I all I had to do to meet my contract was tell
the the chorus that I was having this this meeting. But if you're
saying that like
>> Yeah. She said she said she doesn't let them know. >> All
I have to do is she said this is what the contract says. She
says this is what the contract says and I've never let them know.
>> No, she said like all I have to do is tell them that
I'm having this meeting doing this meeting.
Maybe
featured on a huge page and then suddenly have an onslaugh or
just hey contract viewed by wired creators in the program must
funnel all bookings with lawmakers and political leaders through
chorus. No. Again, I literally have the contract right here.
I'll talk through it in a minute, but first let me show you this.
Here's an email of me directly reaching out to the Zeron campaign
to try to interview him cuz Chorus does not control who I interview
or what I post. I also sometimes text the comm's directors directly
of like Congress people that I want to interview. So I I've not
seen her say she says she has the contract. She didn't say she
was under contract. >> The congressional offices will give
out these little business cards. And this is not like this is
just like if you go to try to talk to your senator, their people
will give you little business cards. I blurt out the name of
the specific person cuz I feel awkward. But like anybody can
get these business cards and then you can just text them. Chorus
does not control that. I've done lots of congressional interviews
and usually I just set them up myself. And here's the section
of the contract, right, that confirms that. It says they want
you to disclose to Chorus any engagement with government officials
related to Chorus's policy agenda. that contractor that's me
I'm the contractor arranges through other means right so if I
just arrange it myself with a congress person I just let chorus
know so that they know that congress person's open to booking
and other people in chorus can do it too I >> so I I think
the implication is there I would just have to she's like saying
what you would have to do and then she says she's never done
it I don't know
I just let them know she if she's saying that she forgets to
do it is she not recognizing that she has an obligation to do
it >> um she might be saying under this she has an obligation
to do it, but she says >> No, what I'm saying is Oh, yeah.
I I forget. So, you can push play on it. >> Black horse.
No, I don't think I've ever told them that before. But that's
not what's important. What's important is that they're literally
acknowledging here that you can book it yourself. And the fact
that the person >> making the claim that oh yeah, I forget
to do this. She's in she is direct she's either directly making
a bold-faced malicious lie because she never had to do this or
she's saying I forgot to do this because I do have an obligation
to do this but I forget and they just sometimes let it slide.
>> I know that this happened with like progressive victory
where there would be certain things that I was contractually
obligated to do, right? Um but sometimes I would forget or whatever
and they just be like, "Yeah, no, no big deal." like >> Yeah,
she she just said some [__] here where she said,
well, it's not that you can't arrange it on your own. That's
not expressed here, right? It says you have to disclose it to
them. You have to do do it through the course newsroom, right?
Disclose to the course newsroom or course newsroom personnel
and then you have to fully collaborate with them regarding any
such separately organized booking. And it just says this like
plainly in the contract. >> Yeah. No, no. This this that's
not the disagreement we're having. The disagreement we're having
is over whether or not this person uh uh is signed a contract
and is maliciously lying about when this contract
uh
was was or or the nature of this this contract and how they can
book. That is why I believe
I believe this Zoran thing that is her saying look I booked with
Zoran. I think that's irrelevant. But I do think that she's also
trying to say that like look, I could just book this on my own
and and I don't even let them know or something and I don't
say I for like why would she state that she forgets to book or
to inform them that she books with people if she is not obligated
to inform them that she booked with people. >> Oh yeah,
I agree that she's obligated. >> Okay. So she is obligated
to book with people, right? So >> to to inform them that
she's booking with people. Yes. >> Yes. Yes. She hasn't
Yes. to inform them that she's booked with people. So your argument
is that then she would be lying
or or dramatically misleading
people about the the nature in which she can uh inform them because
the email was prior to let's just grant that it was prior to
the program or her being a part of the program. I think that
she's like lying or misleading by bringing up that email. >> If
she pulled up that email that that would be her lying. I thought
you agreed with that. I thought you said that. >> No, I
what I would need to show what I would need to see is that that
email and her uh using that story is not indicative of her continued
experience.
That is the argument because her argument is that like she could
have say that again. Say that again. Say that >> So So
she So there's one of two realities in this, right? um either
that she sorry under the perspective that she is not lying about
being a part of the incubator program. If she actually is a part
of the incubator program, right? And she uh the the one reality
is that she has an obligation to disclose
these uh these meetings to uh the choir newsroom.
and she uh uh is
her experience with disclosure is indicative of the Zoron interview,
right? And then so therefore she is using that email even potentially
prior to her signing up to the program to illustrate
how uh uh the process maybe just for like laziness or whatever
it might be. she's just using a email that fell outside of the
date or that she is attempting to shadow how difficult it is
to go through this process by uh uh taking an old email that
was outside of her contract sign up date and she's just going
like, "Oh, it's way harder to do these bookings >> now
that I actually signed this contract." And I'm lying about how
easy or hard it can be. And when I say that, you know, uh oops,
I forgot to disclose,
I'm uh lying
about how
uh lax they are if I don't meet my contractual obligations. >> No,
no, I I don't think any of that matters. I'm saying >> So,
what do you believe? What do you believe happened here? >> I'm
saying the reporting in the article is that this clause exists
and she just shows that this clause exists. And she could say,
I don't disclose, but that doesn't matter. The problem is the
clause existing, right? the the problem they have, not even the
problem. The article suggests the clause exists. This actually
just confirms the reporting in the article. And she could argue
that, oh well, I don't have to do it and that disproves, but
it doesn't disprove because the claim is about what the contract
says. >> Yeah. I I don't disagree that the contract says
this. >> I don't disagree that the contract says it. But
the implication of the implication of the article, if you're
just talking about the article in and it of itself and not her
response to it, >> that the implication of the article
is that this is in some way like trying to control or manipulate
who they talk to. Because I think if people look at the reality
of or at least this woman stated reality of how they handled
the situation, then it's nobody would think that is really bad.
If you if you told people, hey, the reason why we disclose or
we all we have to do is just tell them we're having a conversation
with a politician coming up
like and they go like, huh, why? Well, I mean, maybe it could
be to have this politician be able to potentially book more uh
media uh uh opportunities with various other creators in court
or like I don't think anybody would care. I don't think that's
a bad thing. >> Sure. None of Yeah, but I'm I'm just saying
that like literally all it says here is
that they do this. This is fully
>> This is somebody's quote of how the context of the article
is that it's this shadowy secretive dark money group. >> Uh
I'm just going to take the I'm going to take the factual statements
as factual statements. >> No, no, no. You need to take
it in the context of what Wait, I know you know how this this
is how it works, right? We we both are aware of like 1350 memes,
right? you can state facts well about like the world and put
it in a misleading fashion. And that's what I would argue for
instance that would be uh would be doing in this context, right?
Is that you're putting these these statements into a context
that misleads the reader. >> It's like overly controlling.
Um and they want like access to those politicians. Uh this is
by the way like the least offensive part of this I found. But
I'm just saying that like there is no this hasn't been disproven
at all. Like they don't even really make >> the in the
context of the article that it is that it's some shadowy manipulative.
There's nothing wrong with it. There's no issue with that. You
can't extract it from the context of the article. If you want
to extract it from the context of the article, then we can have
a separate conversation. But the whole point is whether or not
the article accurately portrays chorus and or andor the chorus
incubator program as it exists and that that specific statement
in the context of the article does not >> is 100% accurate.
Following the initial outreach, many creators expressed concern
about stipulations. According to copies of the contract viewed
by Wired, creators in the program must funnel all bookings with
lawmakers and political leaders through Chorus. Creators have
also have to loop course in on any independently organized engagements
with government officials or political leaders. Okay. If I want
to work with another politician, I have to fully collaborate
with them, said one creator who's offered the contract but ultimately
declined to take it and asked not to be named. If I get Zoron
and he wants to do an interview with me, I don't want to give
that to them. So, they're literally just referencing the the
obviously like similar contract language. This person is put
off by it. Like you could say something about the article in
that statement right there. It makes it sound like it's a bad
thing. That's not like what is that >> creator took to
them. >> I I think this is the I think this is the um what
do you call it? I have to fully collaborate with them. I think
they're literally reading that third that third clause and they're
just saying like this is how they take it in, right? This is
how they see it. >> Yes. But I would say and I'm telling
you, can I just ask
contract on earth that isn't >> I understand you think
that you think that the political advocacy group is the same
as McDonald's. That's insane. I don't want to talk about that.
There's not a single talk about that right now in the history
of mankind.
We think that Taylor, if it's incumbent on Taylor Loren to actually
communicate her purpose with this article correctly. I'd say
it's also incumbent on the people creating the contract to not
give people the impression that they want to control their political
contacts. Right. >> No, I don't I don't think that is I
don't I don't There are multiple people who feel like this is
a
case for legal. We're talking one we're talking about straight
up whether or not you have like legal uh whether you're held
liable legally for conduct for people that you take onto a program
and another one is straight up somebody writing an article that
really only I mean you could argue has some legal uh ramifications
for defamation but really the principal uh concern is the ethics
and the the like moral consideration for whether or not you have
the the proof to back up your
There is a far greater standard put on Taylor Lauren's here to
be able to accurately communicate a front-facing public article
meant for public consumption and public interpretation than it
is for article meant to explicitly give a business
political or sorry the best legal advantage when it comes to
uh disputes.
>> I don't think this article is far off. I think the the
by line the initial stuff is a little too far. It's not that
that far too far. And I think basically these factual claims,
this is all factual and people just don't like the slight bend
that that Taylor Loren has against like uh unsourced uh what
would you call like unlimited money in politics. >> Yeah.
No, I
think the context of the article talking about this being a shadowy,
secretive, dark money campaign, I think it leads people to the
obvious conclusion that most people who agree with the article
come to, which is, hey, they're trying to control which politicians
that you talk to and don't talk to. I think that is the very
obvious interpretation that a reasonable reader would interpret
off of this. We could talk about whether or not um actually doesn't
actually strictly say that. And then yeah, we could get into
it doesn't technically say that you can't talk to these people.
I think it is a very obvious implication of the context of the
whole article, but I don't think or I don't think it's implied
at all.
>> Okay, that's pretty wild to me. But um >> either
way, we can we can keep keep reading a little bit more or sorry.
Um, >> and and I would say that the Alley person doesn't
go anywhere near disproving that like anything here like like
literally her her reporting this contract just backs up exactly
what they said gives a lot more credence to the fact the idea
that they have the contract. You're talking about the factual
claims and I and the reason why I watched this video and the
interpretation I got for this video is whether or not the implication
for these claims or whether or not a separate alternative
uh
reason for these various claims could be uh the case and I think
that's what she does. I think she lays out details for >> To
find abuses of contracts like this, you need contracts that have
been getting enforced for like years and years and years, right?
this program as of reading as of writing of the article it existed
for a month and there were concerns about some of the stipulations
they wrote an article about concerns about those stipulations
and so using okay this person who's clearly a didn't report anything
hasn't followed any of their obligations they go well how they
affected me yet uh they're that that defense is stupid I completely
disagree because it shows that many
program that the culture that the culture of the legal stipulations
isn't as harsh as what Wired's making it out to Wired is making
it out to be that every single by line of this contract is legally
binding. It is the death note of legal contracts. They even go
on to say that lawyers uh creators talk about how their lawyers
couldn't redline anything inside of the contracts. They make
it seem like you're signing a deal with the devil. But in if
if creators come out and say, "Hey, bro, this seems to be a pretty
bog standard legal document that every single business in the
history of mankind has ever done ever, which is giving them unlimited
legal latitude, but often not enforcing this unlimited legal
latitude. Uh then yeah, I I I think that this is probably just
the same exact thing as all these different things which is just
a bog standard
between most companies on the planet and a company that is explicitly
paying political creators who are engaging in political speech.
You think there are certain things I think there is a more I
think there's more overlapping I think there's more overlap than
there is
uh different No. >> You think this is the same as like
a contract at McDonald's?
No, for the principle the principal distinction that uh you're
trying to make between the two is I guess like fast food. Um
but like no the princip I am trying to state is that every single
business in the history of mankind and every single business
that will exist into perpetuity will maximize their legal advantage
inside of any kind of dispute by making these very broad legally
statements
um for any type of uh uh stipulation. >> So you agree that
the contracts are potentially could be could be abused but we
just don't have proof that they would be abused. >> Yeah,
they could. Yeah, 100%. Just like every other business ever.
Yes. >> So, the article is concerned about how the contracts
could be abused, right? And whistleblowers contacting Taylor
Ren to complain about how the contracts could be abused. So,
the article, in my opinion, is quite factual. No, because the
this this the overwhelming
thesis of the article is that it's this shadowy, secretive, dark
money group that is secretly pushing creators to tow the party
lines to push a specific political message. Not only is this
the explicit
of the the the actual article, also this is the interpretation
of many of the readers who agree with >> like write some
stuff down. I think we need to like write some stuff down because
I'm going to I'm going to ask you again. Do you think that you
could reasonably interpret pushing the party line as paying mostly
Democrat- aligned me uh messaging people, mostly Democratic line
creators to make content two, three, four, five times as often
as they were able to when this wasn't their full-time job. You
enable them to do that, right? And you don't have a 100% alignment,
but you have like 90%. You do daily messaging updates. You do
advocacy training where you teach them policy in the exact way
you you think it should be like uh like thought about, right?
And you do rapid responsibly
are like this is how you talk explicitly about all of these different
things. Can I see that? >> Well, she she says, well, we'll
get to it in this, right? But she talks about how she's got an
advocacy training and they bring in a policy expert and they
tell their they go deep on like some policy, right? >> Yeah,
they go deep on policy. But I what your statement what you just
said was different, which is that they talk about policy in the
way that they explicitly want creators to talk about it. So they
say, "Hey, this, hey guys, this is how X and Y and Z policy should
be talked about this week." Do we have any proof of that? Do
we have any proof that the I I would assume that they're not
going to that they're like a they're a group that's dedicated
to like specific um what do you call it? They're like an issues
based group. They're trying to say they're nonpartisan. I'm guessing
that they have some like code or some uh like they they say they
have a policy platform or something like that. I forget what
the exact thing policy agenda. I assume it's in line with their
policy agenda, right? >> Uh it depends. I don't I don't
know what their policy agenda is to be honest. >> And nor
nor do I
mean in the context nor do I really know what that means in the
context of these contracts or their obligations? Do you do you
think they pay these influencers to go to advocacy trainings
where they get them to go deep on a policy with an expert and
they pay an expert who's like actually like a creationist to
come and teach them about like fossil fuel like fossil fuels
in the environment? Do you think that that's very likely? >> I
don't know. I I probably have >> Okay. All right. It's
unknowable. >> I mean, do you know do you have any >> Nope.
I'm not I don't know why we're Why are we speculating? Why? Just
be like I don't know. Why are we why are we speculating on this
political group that's funded by political that a political dark
like a a liberal known liberal dark money group why do we think
that the policy agenda might be in line with liberal values and
and talking about policy from like a liberal align perspective
okay why when we're having a factual discussion of the whether
or not this group is pushing people secretively pushing people
to push the party lines why are we performing conjecture why
are we doing this when we have people when we have people who
have way more
at all who are giving any conjecture information on it >> cuz
you're the one saying this is conjecture there's no there's no
actual read the whole article there's no actual proof anywhere
that anybody was pushed to do anything
>> I I didn't say there was >> okay so but the by
line does the by line says that they were pushed to be able to
they were pushed to push the agenda >> do you do you think
you could pay somebody to do something and convince them to do
it without telling them that if they don't do it they won't get
paid Is that possible? >> Yeah, of of course you're able
to do that. But I would expect in the article that claims this
to substantiate why that's the case. And it doesn't
merit to the party line uh pushes or prompts them to come to
that conclusion. All of these different things do not push you
into that direction.
>> I totally disagree.
>> Okay. Can you give me this? Can you give me the paragraph
inside of this article that says clearly that this is where in
the contract it says that >> you it implies that >> but
you know that that's not my argument. So I don't know why you
would ask for it. >> No, you know that's not my argument.
So I don't know why you as talking about the implication where
inside of the article it's it substantiates the idea that if
you do not tow the party line you don't get paid.
>> I've literally said there is no explicit thing anywhere
or implication. >> I said implication. Stop. I've actually
Okay, I've actually told you and you've agreed with me that you
don't have to cut the people off who don't tow the party line.
>> Okay, I Hey, listen to my words. Where in this article
is a
substantiate substantiate for me? Substantiate for me. So, you
need to substantiate for me really quickly.
I'm still I'm just going to go through this and say that you
need to substantiate for me that they have to be cut off for
the for the broad the broad basis for this to be the broad context
of this group to be they're paying influencers to push the party
Can you let me finish talking for two seconds like real quick?
I just want to finish this point.
Okay. I'm asking you, why do I need to have even an implication
that somebody loses their money to have them push the party line
if I'm trying to pay people who already push the party line to
push it more?
>> And the reason why is because you're making the claim
that they're being paid money to push the party line. You just
ask why do I need proof or an implication that people are being
paid money to push the party line if I'm going to claim that
they're being paid money to push the party line? Gee, I wonder
why.
>> What do you mean? >> I'm I'm trying. >> You
need an implication. So where does it push the party line
party line? >> Do you push the party line? Are you broadly
aligned with Democratic talking >> Yeah, I'm broadly aligned.
Yeah. >> If I paid you to stream 80 hours a week when you're
broadly aligned, am I paying to push the party line? >> Uh,
it depends on why you're paying me. Am I >> unequivocally?
No, it does not. Unequivocally yes. I'm saying I love what you're
doing. I want to pay you to do it more. It's unequivocally yes.
>> Yes. What? >> It's unequivocally yes. I am paying
for the party line to be pushed. Oh, well then yeah, you're stating
explicitly that you want you're paying me money to push the party
line. >> No, I'm just paying you. >> You just said
yes. It is because you wanted me to put Which one is it? Did
you just >> unequivocally I'm telling you that the answer
is yes.
>> Okay. So, you tell me you are paying me money to push
the party line. Therefore, I believe that you are paying me to
push the party line. If I c can I can I ask you if I paid $5,000
to Mike from PAN
Denims all these people. Let's say a bunch of them were let's
go like lower Greml like a bunch of these loser leftists. Okay.
I'm paying them so they can make content full-time. Am I paying
to promote like terrorist propaganda? >> It depends on
why you're paying those creators. You could be paying them for
what are they Palestinian advocacy? You could be paying them
for like being socialist, prominent socialists online. You could
be paying them for like like transphobia stuff. You could be
just paying them because you like uh like uh I don't know, maybe
you just like news being covered on their stream. Frankly, I
don't watch all of them enough to know what they all do. >> Okay.
I I think the basically you can pay somebody to continue what
they're doing to do it more often and that could be accomplishing
a goal and you don't have to tell them that they have to do anything
different. You should say I'm going to pay you to do this more.
>> Yeah. And I don't I don't think that that is sufficient
to make the hard claim that you're they're being paid money to
push the party line when there is no evidence whatsoever that
even when they go against the party line that they will stop
being paid.
>> We don't need that. I I think we've established pretty
clearly. >> Yeah. No, I I think you do need that. I think
you need some element of when people go against the party line,
when they literally push against the party politic that they
will stop getting paid, have a reduced salary, do something because
otherwise what you're just saying is they look for people who
push the party line and if they end up not pushing the party
line, then they still get paid anyway. >> So, I'm I'm going
to go back to they're paying creators with this with this bend.
Uh Brian Tyler Cohen has explicitly said that this is about getting
Democratic messaging out there to make Democrats more effective.
And not only that, I I do believe eventually they would be cutting
people off. If one of these if like if 10 of these creators just
went full on Trump, okay, they're full on MAGA. You think they
just keep paying them? You think they keep bringing them back?
>> No. Probably they probably not. No, I I do believe that
it is like a a a pro-democrat
like uh group, but I don't see any argument to say that their
content is restricted outside of that, like outside of just not
being MAGA.
>> So, I don't know if they've actually made the claim
that the content is restricted. We'll see. I It has been It's
restricted in some way, right? It's just restricted in some way.
So, I think what's restricted is >> they can't be pro Trump.
Sure.
No, I'm not even making that argument. I'm saying the restrictions
I don't think are like on the topics of the content. I think
they're or like I don't think they're saying restrictions ideologically.
I think they're saying restrictions on like it seems like mostly
FC stuff, right? Like electioneering. I think that's where the
restrictions are coming in. >> I mean, they literally say
and agree to restrictions on their content in the by >> Yes.
Yes. So, it's restrictions on the content, but it's mo mostly
with respect to uh electioneering, right? like as in you have
to check with us if you're going to talk about like certain things.
The obvious implication of this entire article is that they're
like any reasonable person reading this article is going to think
Chorus as an entire group pays content creators to push very
specific messaging that they cate and only will let them talk
to very specific politicians that they curate and in the contract
they aren't allowed to disclose their participation in chorus
and they aren't allowed to disclose how much money they make
with chorus. It's like that is the very obvious implication of
this article.
um traders must also loop.
So this is this already disproves what you just said. So you
publicly talk about your participation in chorus but maybe potentially
not this incubator program. We didn't get a specific on that
is >> Okay. Um I have to stop one specific thing. You just
said that the the a regular read reasonable reader would infer
that you cannot talk to politicians that they don't want you
to. And yet it says creators must also loop course in on any
independently organized engagements with government officials
or political leaders. It's like actually explicitly saying they
can. >> That's not explicit. Wait, that I you are you've
lost your mind. If you think that explicitly states that you
can talk to whoever you want to. When it says creators also have
to loop uh loop chorus in on any independently organized engagements,
it sounds like they're asking their daddy for permission. >> It
doesn't. especially with the next paragraph. If I want to work
with another politician, I have to fully collaborate with them.
So, one creator was after a contract but ultimately declined
and asked if I want to get Zoron and I wanted he wants to do
an interview with me. I don't want >> I just want you to
agree. Yes or no? Is this a direct quote from the contract? Is
that directly quoting a contract >> If I what that thing
that you're highlighting? No. >> You have to fully collaborate
with Chorus
when when individually like scheduling your own [__]
Oh yeah
inside of the contract explicitly. Okay, >> Wait, you just
said something totally and just decided to abandon my previous
point. My my point was that the article clearly is implying that
you have to because you just for some reason read something in
a brain deadad way. Creators also have to loop chorus in on any
independently organized engagements. You read that as apparently
evidence that it's saying that you can just you're allowed to
you're allowed to engage with any politician that you want explicitly
loop chorus in on in the context of these two paragraphs in the
context of this whole lead a reasonable reader to interpret that
you cannot
>> you can you can say it with incredility all you want
but it is explicitly saying you can independently organize your
own you should still let them know >> no you have to loop
It's crazy to me that you you you're you don't there is no way
that you are reading this and you're just like this is explicitly
like this. This is just explicitly
the only the only interpretation the most reasonable interpretation
when very obviously in the full context of the Wired article
it is heavily implying that you cannot do it without permission.
>> Uh I don't think it's I don't think that's the implication.
>> That's crazy. Okay, just
happens to just coincidentally
see the way that I'm saying that people are going to read it.
Just it's a pure coincidence. The way I'm articulating the article
just happens to be the way that all of these different people
who agree with the article interpret it. It just happens to be
that every single last one of them who breathe air [__]
interpreted it that way.
>> I didn't interpret it that way and a bunch of like straight
array didn't interpret it that way. A bunch of people who read
this >> I'm sure that way. Yes, I'm I'm sure. >> Okay.
Uh, so a bunch of people I've talked to um are capable of reading.
So you could say like, oh, like a who reads >> No, not
a I'm talking about a reasonable person who reads an article
talking about a secretive a shadowy group that takes dark money
and is funding uh Democratic uh political content creators to
push specific types of content for
a month. No, I don't think it's unreasonable to talk about when
they're restricted, they're they're talking about who which politicians
you can talk to, whether or not they control which politicians
you talk to. >> Do you think it's possible for a reasonable
person to read a title and by line and then read an article,
consume an article, and realize that the title and by line were
like hyperbolic and possibly clickbait? uh usually no that is
literally the point of a headline is that most people especially
in today's uh realm that most people are going to read the title
and the by line and are going to that is going to color the rest
of their interpretation of the article most of the time that
is the case. >> Okay. So I like this is uh I guess you
could you could say this. So I read the article like actually
with a critical eye. So I guess when you say a reasonable person
you mean like the average person which is fine. I'm just average
reasonable person, not somebody who's like sitting inside of
these environments or whatever. I'm talking about your average
Joe Mo who's a construction worker who's just working his [__]
job and his hobby is watching football. Okay? We're not talking
on Twitch all day or kick all day. We're talking about average
Joe Schmoes who are just like, "Yeah, you know what? I'm just
going to read an article about some dark money group." >> Do
we think the average Joe Schmo
reads articles like this? No, I don't. But I think if they think
this article probably leads, their obvious interpretation is
that this is some secretive uh group that pushes content creators
to make very specific tailored content to what their their mission
objective is and that those content creators have restrictions
on the types of politicians they can talk to. >> Are you
concerned about the average person reading this or are you concerned
about like someone who which are you more concerned about the
average person or Hassan? Like which one? >> Average person.
Okay.
Uh, can you show me some like where are you seeing the average
person's like feedback on this article?
I I am uh being told it's uh Listen, I got to I got to bring
the temperature down. Okay. My roommates are sleeping. >> Little
loud. Okay. Yeah, my bad. >> The What did you just ask
me? >> Uh, where are you where are you tapping into the
average person's read on this article? Um I I would say based
on how uh
like I have understood people to interpret articles and messaging
in the past is how I'm tapping in on this. I'm reading it and
I'm reading it through a lens that I believe that most other
articles have been interpreted by average Joe Schmo like people
reading articles from like the New York Times, the Washington
Post, the Wall Street Journal, these things. I'm reading it with
that interpretation. So when an article comes out talking about
um Mayor Eric Adams and his uh misconduct or Donald Trump and
his dealings with Epstein or these different things, I look at
the public reception of these articles. Um a great example is
actually the uh Signal Group Chat Atlantic article um and what
the public's interpretation of that. I'm using the public's reception
of the way that these articles are characterized and I'm interpreting
this one through that lens. >> Okay. I'm see I don't I'm
not tapped into those like you are. So I'm just making like claims
based on what I'm reading. You know what I mean? Like and how
I interpret it and like what the obvious language of the article
is. >> Um sure it might be obvious to you how the language
is. But I think that for a the average reasonable reader who
their interpretation with dark money groups is that and especially
dark money groups who pay uh like uh uh political organizations
to push messaging. It's that if you do not push this messaging,
you're cut out from the group and that it's paying explicitly
people to push a very specific message. especially in the shadow
of like tenant media and stuff like that that we saw where people
like very explicitly were paid money to do some of these things.
>> Do you think do you think you could look at this let's
say we took the title and the by line away?
>> Do you think if you looked at it through that context
do you have anywhere near the problem with the article that you
have now?
>> Uh it's a lot less. It's a lot less. >> Okay.
I think um I think this is probably the biggest problem I have
with the article as well is this by line. I I think I don't even
care about this one. I understand the the clickbait. Um I'm not
as big a I don't have as big an issue with this, but the the
by line I think is hyperbolic and I do think there's no direct
tie. I do think in my opinion like based on you know if I'm if
I'm trying to define what the goal of this is. I think I think
this is the goal. I believe this is the goal 100%. I would not
use this as a by line but only because I don't have a lot of
proof for that and this group would need to exist for longer
for me to prove that out. But if I had to if I had to guess using
my you know whatever whatever uh subheading I like by line what
do you mean subheading fine subheading whatever this subheading
okay
um I just think you can't prove it but I I think this is accurate
honestly and I I think it's for the the pola reason basically
like I I do believe that's what it will come down to. Um I think
they've explicitly stated this a group meant to to help Democrats
push messaging on the internet. I think that's been a part of
their goal explicitly from the very beginning. And I just don't
I I think they've set it up in a way where they can accept really
large amounts of money to to make this work or or money. I would
say not even large amounts of money. I'd say they they can accept
money from um sources that can throw money away and without naming
them, right? They can just throw a bunch of money away. Uh I
think that's more what it is. Like billionaires who can just
throw like, you know, hundred,000 or a million dollars at this
and not really worry about it. That's that's my suspicion. But
I I would never have put this as a title for an article I was
writing because I think you it's very difficult to prove and
you need more time. Um I think most of the article itself is
about >> I think the primary issue is that it colors the
rest of the article. But e even still let's just finish up the
chick's video. The principal thing that I care about is within
5 minutes I believe the entire contract. >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> But like here it is clearly written that what you stated
in your article was categorically false. Like that is quite concerning
about your journalistic integrity. Like I get >> so there
there's nothing that's categorically false in the article. Um
especially in the section she's referring to talking about that.
>> I agree nothing is categorically false. I wouldation
on on undo
though >> are long and confusing. That's why people have
lawyers and managers to help them. But you don't write an article
about it unless you understand what's going on. This whole article
is just written like you know this group they have money and
so they control them and it's just like no that's not that's
not what's happening. there is someone in this cohort that you
are like they are too much of a shill doing whatever the Democratic
party says. It's not this program that's the reason for that.
I don't know how to put this nicely. It's either a personal moral
failing by those people or it's a different contract they're
under that says they can't criticize Dems. But it's not this
one because I'm under this contract and you can catch me on the
daily making fun of >> I just I don't see an implication
here that says they can't criticize Dems.
Wait, stop. Stop. There is an implication because it says tow
the party line in the by line. >> Push the party line.
>> That is the implication that you can't criticize the
Dems is that you tow the party line. Do you disagree with that?
>> They there's no obvious implication of >> push
the party line. >> Pushing the party line is different
than towing the party line. Towing the party line means shutting
your mouth. Pushing the party line means advocating for the things
they do positively. >> No shot. You So you believe when
it says eight you get influencers are getting paid $8,000 a month
to post the party line. All they have to do is keep it a secret
and agree to restrictions on their content. You would say that
it's a wild idea that it could be implying that you can't criticize
Democrats. It's a wild idea. It doesn't make any sense that there
would be an implication, a hint that you couldn't criticize
>> Uh so I would say that you not going to spend time criticizing
Democrats, right? That you'd be be being paid to push like on
policy issues. No, that's not what I'm asking because her point
and a point of a lot of these other people is that that you that
you are not allowed to push back against uh Democrats because
you're agreeing to restrictions on your content and push you're
getting paid money to push the party line. You think that is
a wild implication that they're
restrictions. I think push the party line. I don't think that
necessarily means you can't criticize Democrats, but I do think
agree to restrictions on their content. You could read it into
that one maybe. Yeah, I I I would say that's the most reasonable
interpretation of a article tackling this group as a a a dark
money secretly
>> I think this is trying to get people hooked into the
article and I think people clickbait really hard in these parts
and I do think that if you read articles like I I'm mostly understanding
that I have to go read the meat of the article and reading the
title and and the the subheading that I'm probably going to get
misled by people trying to get clicks.
What? >> Yeah. No, I think the because you keep saying
that you you said this even before that it's very like nobody's
making the claim that you can't criticize Democrats. I think
that's total.
This by line in conjunction with the the title, all of this stuff
paints a very clear narrative literally before you start the
article at all that you cannot criticize the uh the the
Dems to any substantive degree. You can't. >> Um, okay.
I I don't think that would be disagree with me. So, okay. What
I would what I would say is
I think that
there's no reason to think that you would that if you didn't
want criticism for Democrats, then and this is just we're never
going to agree on this, right? I don't think you need anything
that says we negatively we we negatively uh enforce this policy.
I think you positively enforce and you have enough money that
you just pay people and you let people drop out who aren't positively
enforcing stuff, right? >> No, that's not that's stop.
That's not the the principal concern. The principal concern is
whether or not there is the idea that you can't criticize Democrats.
You can't do that. Your So is your argument anybody who criticizes
the Dems are getting kicked out of this program? >> Uh
that they just wouldn't be that they just say, "Oh, that's money
we missed." >> Really? So, you for instance think they're
going to kick this chick out of the program?
>> No, I don't think this chick actually criticizes Democrats.
I think being this person also >> she has.
>> Sure. I think uh criticizing Democrats on Israel Palestine
will be like a cutout issue where they don't want to lose people
their
>> Isn't that literally the hottest issue that like people
on the left criticize
>> Yeah. It's also the issue where you probably need the
party to change and not not the uh the influencers.
>> like the clear the biggest divisive issue amongst left-leaning
people being able to criticize the Dems for is not actionable
in your mind for termination of contract. >> So if they
were if this was in 2000, I think they could have gay marriage
up there and it would be something that splits Dems really hard,
but it wouldn't be something that they would say you can't criticize
Dems over. >> Yeah. So,
uh, yeah, I I think when these people make content, all these
different people make content saying it's that you can't criticize
this idea that you can't criticize uh the Democrats um that this
article is talking about. I think it's very obvious that the
article is making that implication. I think it's extremely heavy
implication. And so yeah, that's why these people are uh saying,
"Hey, this is a lie pushed by the article because that is an
implication that the article is drawing." >> What do you
feel about the fact that Telev is trying to correct that stuff?
>> Um, I would say that's good for her to try and correct
it and I'd hope she would speak out against the by line in the
title. >> I don't think she thinks the by line's >> Okay.
Well, then I would argue then she's written and she's not actually
speaking out against it. Yeah, I think uh there's a way for me
to make this argument that it would make sense, but um yeah,
I I think you could absolutely do this and I don't think I think
one um you actually can't given the structure actually kick people
out for criticizing Democrats. I think then you you would immediately
be facing FC violations, but I don't think that's because they
won't drop people who are overly critical of Democrats or not
not towing the party line uh to use my wording or your wording,
right? I I think they will do that. I think that's obviously
like the goal is to push democratic messaging online. I think
that's obviously the goal. And so, >> sure, it's the goal
is to push democratic messaging online. Sure. Um but this idea
that you can't deviate from any of the messaging of like the
like pro dem the party line is
>> Yeah. I don't I think I think you're taking push the
party line and like basically saying that's like not colorful
language. It's colorful language. I don't see a huge difference
between pushing Democratic messaging on the internet and towing
the party line. I just don't see a significant difference between
those two states. >> It's about people interpreting this
article as saying that you cannot criticize Dems.
And that is a very reasonable interpretation from this article
just based on the by line even alone, which you you can't disagree.
Most people are going to if they're going to read the article,
they're going to read the by line. Like the the headline and
the by line is most people who even touch this article, that's
all they're going to >> Maybe, but I like I said, I'm just
I'm looking at what the article says, right? So, I I can't really
I can't really speculate on what the average person >> I
mean, we can we can be reasonable. You can be like saying an
initiative aimed at boosting Democrats online uh offers influencers
$8,000 a month up to $8,000 a month to push the party line. All
they have to do is keep it a secret and agree to restrictions
on their content. You would say that that doesn't imply that
they can't criticize Democrats. >> So, let's say we we
publicized every influencer. Okay. And actually like there's
like four who push against the party in in like 10% of their
content and other than that nobody pushes against the party at
all. Would you say it's still incorrect? Would you still say
that that subheading the what we're calling the by line was incorrect?
>> I I would need more details. I'm I'm not so I need more
details.
>> Okay. So, they're basically only paying people who push
the party line. Do you think the the subheading is now incorrect?
Why do you >> I need more details. I'm not [__]
I'm not a chimp, so I actually need more
>> What more information? I've just told you that basically
uh what? So, >> what more information could I need before
making a dramatic claim about >> 10% of their content pushes
back against the Democratic party? >> I'm I'm literally
giving you a hypothetical that should be really easy to agree
to. >> Yes. And I'm telling you, I do not I do not feel
comfortable making any claim about a group that I have very insufficient
information to make a claim about. So I just wouldn't make a
claim. If you're are you asking me what I would have at a guess,
my best guess would be or you are saying if I giving you the
exact ratio of the content and it's like essentially 99.9%
prodem content, would you say the by line is wrong, the the subheading
is wrong? >> Yeah. No. I Yeah. No. No. I would need more
information before I claim that know whether or not it's right
or wrong. I need more information. >> Okay. Uh I I totally
disagree that that's required based on the language >> Okay.
I mean I think that when we're doing investigative journalism,
we should actually have like standards of not inductive like
uh stuff. I think that's perfectly fine for like Twitch poll.
I think that's actually perfectly fine for like kick and stuff
like that. But when we're talking about actual investigative
journalism, ah, that's pretty at least by the standard that I
use when I read actual real articles on like Epstein and that
is like a standard. That is a dog standard. >> Um, this
company is clearly pushing a specific political agenda because
they're only paying people inside of red states. It's Oh, okay.
Well, you know, surely the Medicaid programs that we just authorized
is pushing a conservative agenda because they're only funding
Medicaid states. or sorry Medicaid and red states won the election
for Trump doing this. Yeah. Elon literally won the election doing
this for Trump. This exact thing. >> Yeah. But it was very
obvious what when and there was many different elements that
were principally different for Elon Musk and that I would say
could lead a reasonable person to that conclusion.
>> Why Why is it different? >> Because he had direct
advertisements saying like W Trump. >> Oh, I'm not talking
about his advertising. I'm talking about his like lottery like
getting out the vote. Um >> well okay. Yeah. I wouldn't
say I wouldn't say the lottery in and of itself was like
would be sufficient. Just get out and vote lottery um would be
sufficient to just be like, "Hey, this guy is pro Trump." I think
you would need in context his favorability to Trump, people who
like him knowing that he likes Trump, his proTrump messaging
and stuff like that. I think if somebody just holds a lottery
to like go out and vote, I don't think that automatically means
they're pro Trump or pro Biden. >> Sure. But what he did
was he used data from X to advertise almost certainly to nearly
exclusively Trump voters.
>> Right? That >> that's nearly impossible to to
to that's nearly impossible to prove and he would have probably
had other people getting involved in there. He wouldn't have
blocked anybody from seeing those advertisements or signing up.
Right. He would never have blocked them. So he wouldn't have
been pushing the Republicans explicitly.
But in effect he was pushing the Republican line. >> Yeah.
because he had an algorithm specifically tailored to target these
>> Yes. And I'm saying that that's why I'm saying that
given a selection of influencers, you could do this. And I think
they believe that that is the
>> Yeah. I don't see. So I'm giving you examples of creators,
you're watching examples of creators who do not believe they
have these same restrictions on their content. They feel free
to criticize the Democratic party. They don't feel like their
contracts are going to get squeezed. And so they're doing it.
>> Sure. Is that most of their content is criticizing the
Democratic party? >> No, they're still overwhelmingly
uh like prodem. Yeah. >> Okay. So when they push an overwhelmingly
prodemn
message, even the ones that do criticize Dems occasionally, they
all push an overwhelmingly prodemn message. They are paying to
push the party line. >> I disagree. >> Now, okay.
Yeah. Okay. So Elon Musk because he wasn't actually uh like we
also can't prove the algorithm thing. I just assume when he shows
Trump his phone and says look we're easily going to win Pennsylvania
and then they they win Pennsylvania like I I just assume that
uh >> like there's there's
there's the example you gave for Elon Musk isn't even like a
great one. There's multiple different examples for Elon Musk
where it was very obvious he was like committing some kind of
violation at very minimum ethical maybe legal for like >> I'm
talking about where he's like trying to have plausible deniability
with regards to the FC. >> Uh and sure >> I think
I think that's basically what's happened here is they um
>> they they have plausible deniability with the FC, but
they're basically just all pushing a Democratic messaging or
they're all pushing Democratic messaging. They are trying their
best to push democratic messaging online. And to me, when you
when you categorize that as they're offering influencers to push
the party line, I think in aggregate that is what they are doing.
Absolutely. Not even remotely questionable. When you put that
together with and agree to restrictions on their content, some
people could infer some people could infer that it means you
can't criticize Dems. I don't know why because that would be
because that not only would that put them in trouble with the
FCC
interpretation for like all people is that they can't criticize
them to do what the Dem say. >> I think you just set up
something where you've just like allowed all insane like political
interference or political >> metal. So let me just hear
excuse all of >> Let me let me just get this on record.
This statement, an initiative aimed at boosting Democrats online
offers influencers up to $8,000 a month to push the party line.
All it has to do is keep it a secret and agree to restrictions
on their content. You don't believe that a unbelievable implication
of this is that you cannot criticize Democrats? >> Um,
even if that were an implication, I don't think >> I'm
just No, no, no. Answer the question. Is the overwhelming implication
of this that you can't >> Sorry. It's that it's that it's
that you're not paying in aggregate for people to criticize Democrats.
And I don't believe there's any indication that that is the case.
>> Okay. So you don't believe the implication of this is
that So just to be clear, you don't believe the implication of
this is that you can't criticize Democrats. >> I think
the implication of this is not that if that I think whatever
the implication of this is, it's not disproven by two people
criticizing Democrats three times. >> That's not what I'm
asking. Why are you being so snaky? Is the main implication
that the implication >> is the main implication of this
that you can't criticize Democrats? >> No, I don't think
it is that you can't criticize All right. So then we just we
principally disagree on this. >> Okay. All right. >> I
I don't know how you can read agree to restrictions on their
content and push the party line and believe that. Yeah. No, you're
just >> you're totally free to criticize down. I don't
know how you can do that, but that's fine. >> I I'll I'll
tell you, if you only read this, if you only read this and looked
no further, maybe you could take that >> No, show me where
in this article. Show me where in this article it says they were
able to criticize Dems. Show me >> Why would they have
to say that?
because it you're you're saying like if you only read that if
you read the whole article, it doesn't contest the idea that
they were or it doesn't uh yeah it it doesn't push against the
idea that they were allowed to criticize the the Dems. It says
nowhere that they were able to make free content. In fact, the
implication is that they were not allowed to freely make content.
It gets several quotes from several different people talking
about concerns of restrictions on their content of whether or
not they can disclose and stuff like that. this idea that like
this article if you read it, it's only the high headline in the
by line that talks about like the uh restrictions on their content.
This is ridiculous. It nowhere in the article does it say, "Oh
yeah, by the way, our by line, it's kind of you actually are
able to criticize the uh the Dems." It says nowhere and it implies
that you can't. >> I I just disagree, but it's I I think
we I think there can be implications here and I think you can
get this exact same We can't disagree because I asked you a question.
Show me where in this article it says that you're allowed to
criticize >> where in this article it says that you you
can't criticize Dems. >> Right in the by line your your
your >> I've already my question back to you. I've already
in this article already said, "Show me where in this article
maybe you could think this is where it's leading, but after
we already principally disagree on this content, I think the
most reasonable interpretation is that." And I think that I think
the proof is in the pudding for me that pretty much everybody
who read this article believes that you weren't allowed to freely
speak and criticize. >> Where is the proof? Okay. Where's
the proof? [__] all these different people that are
[__] reading this thing are saying that. Yeah. know
these people were restricted with what they can and can't say
>> what I wanted to ask you. So I think >> No, no,
no. Stop. Stop. Because I asked you a question you refused to
answer. Show me where in this article it says that they were
freely able to criticize the Dems. >> That doesn't exist.
>> Okay. So it doesn't exist. >> I've never that
needed to exist. I have no idea why that needs to exist. >> Let
me just put it make it clear. My evidence for the existence of
the the idea that they had restrictions or or the implication
that they couldn't criticize the Dems is the by line statement
which I feel like in very obviously implies that and your evidence
for um >> the idea that they they or sorry
the article as a whole does anything to dissuade away from that
and you agree that nothing else inside of the article dissuades
away from the idea that they can't criticize the Dems.
>> Okay. I just So, one um Taylor Loren doesn't control
the by line or the title. Uh that is that or or it would be she
has control over it in that she can choose to not run the story
with that by line because she can be like, "No, I will not put
my name on this article with that by line." She has some >> Okay.
Uh so, okay. So, she could basically like take this this article
she worked months on and say, "Actually, no, we're not publishing
it now. I know you put all these resources in. I actually don't
know what contract she signed, but you're saying she should protest
this article now because of because of this. Even though her
words don't do anything with this, even though her words, >> you
said that she stands, but I'm I'm telling you that like that
they're pushing the party line. I've already explained how you
could do that precisely with no explicit no explicit or implicit
cut against people who speak negatively of the uh Democrat party.
>> Okay. Subheading. If you keep saying by line, Porter
Beller is going to kill himself. So don't uh don't say don't
say by line again. It's subheading >> By line it's done.
Get out of here. >> Headers headers and subheads come out
after the body of an article was written and she had already
signed an exclusivity agreement with Wired. So you think on principle
because of the so do you believe that so if they if she signed
an exclusivity deal with them she can't run the story anywhere
else they put all the resources into this you think she should
have basically protested and and tried to like walk and say you
can't publish this because of the title and by line they >> I
will not I will not walk with this because it is a misrepresentation
of the article if that is your point I don't believe it is a
misrepresentation of the article and I think that's the whole
point of many of the different protests against it as I think
the implication of the article is too much it's It's more than
what the article actually says. The implication of the artic
or sorry more than what the article actually has to prove. The
implication of the article is that choir or chorus as an entire
group is this dark money secretive group that is paying uh influencers
to be able to push specific messaging and restrict the content
that they make in order to uh uh push very specific uh ideas.
And they just they just simply don't have the proof for that.
They don't have the it doesn't meet muster. And moreover, um,
this is coming from somebody who reads articles daily. I know
what the standards are for art, uh, articles, and this is not
it, dude. This is dog compared to the standard for what is necessary
for for being able to claim that. Yeah. This is >> You
give me like a three paragraph section you think um specifies
this like >> specifies what the spirit of the article >> that
is like dog that it's a dog
>> Okay. So the by line um >> no we're uh we're well
I'm talking about the article itself. So the Taylor Loren author
part I want the three paragraph section maybe five article. No
>> I'm asking you about the meat of the article based on
the things written by >> No I I totally reject this. The
headline of an article is probably the most important part of
the article. Number one it's the thing that most people are going
to see. Number two, it's a it's a a fair number of people are
only going to engage with the article uh the headline. And number
three, >> you're just going to argue that it's it's not
at all about the the meat of the article. >> No, it Hey,
why why why are we doing this? Why are we pretending right now?
I said you said give me three paragraphs. I gave you one and
then you contested the first one and then now you're trying
I'm giving you number one of three. I'm giving you number one
of three. You asked me for three. I gave you one. And then you
said
you're misunderstanding me. You're not watching me. So I'm highlighting
like a three paragraph section. I'm saying given the meat of
the article. >> Yeah. I I can No, I can see that
section. I'm I'm not saying three disjoint paragraphs. I'm saying
a three paragraph section that makes it a article as written
by Taylor Loren. >> What? Why would I have to highlight
a three paragraph section? >> You say it's a shitty article
and you are obviously saying it's just entirely the title. And
then when I tell you that you're saying it's entirely the title,
you go, "Why are we doing this right now?" I'm telling you to
please highlight the three paragraph to five paragraph section
that you think makes a bad point seven. I think the article in
its entirety is bad like in its full >> Sure. What is the
critique of this part of the article specific three >> Can
you give me your critique of the meat of the article that makes
it poorly written? Yes. So, I'm saying if we gave this a different
title, if we gave this,
I'm giving it a different title. I'm giving it a different title
and subheading, and I want you to tell me what makes it article
after that point. I'm Let's say they updated. Let's say they
updated it. Wait, that's literally not how it works. >> I
I just want to talk about Taylor
if it hypothetically had a different title because we >> I'm
laughing because >> I'm laughing because you say horribly
written article entire critique is the >> earlier as No,
you >> critique is is summed up as you dislike the title.
>> Why do you keep pretending? Stop pretending.
Just stop. So right now, so you asked me a lot way earlier if
it the title was removed, would my criticism of the article uh
be void? And I said, "No, but for the most part, it's most of
my criticism come from." >> In that world, can you give
me the parts of the article you disagree with? >> In the
world where it had no title
>> yeah. Or subheading. >> Okay. Um, it would be
the uh specific part of the what we went over with the politicians,
like interviewing politicians. I think the implication of that
isn't just that, hey, you just let us know and we're good because
I don't think many people, almost anybody would think that's
like a bad thing that all you have to do is just let them know
and even in some situations you if you don't let them know, it's
not a big deal. Um, so I don't think that uh I don't think that
that's I don't think that's material. I don't think anybody really
cares about that. Uh, I think colored inside of the context of
the whole article, it implies that they need to you need preapproval
as to who you interview, which politicians you interview. Uh,
I think >> I don't believe that. And can I just also point
out that when I asked you why you think it implies that, you
said it was the in the context of the article given and that
you quoted the subheading. No, I I quote, "No, I I believe this
in and it of itself stands as something that that that implies
that you need preapproval to be able to um
uh talk to politicians. And moreover, if it was honest or transparent
about the actual underlying nature of how it works, it's not
a bad thing. Nobody would consider this to be a bad I think your
average Joe Schmo would be like, "Hey, if you do an interview
with a politician, just let us know." I don't think anybody would
consider that to be a bad thing. So, with that in mind, that
if they reported on it honestly, nobody would consider it to
be a bad thing. And with the way that they reported on it, it
implying that it is a bad thing, um, I think that is dishonest
and I don't like that. Uh, another portion of the article that
uh I don't like, which they literally had to add stuff to, is
the contract reviewed by Wire prohibits standard partnership
disclosures, which in the video with the woman she gets into.
Uh, but beyond uh on the next sentence, declaring uh that creators
will not publicize their relationship with Chorus. This is false.
Or tell others that they're members of the program. This might
be true. This is uh and I'll grant that based on their their
reviewing of a uh contract that this they believe it to be true,
but the first part of this is false. They are allowed to declare
that they have a relationship with Chorus. Now, they are not
necessarily allowed to >> just real quick, I have to cut
in.
>> So, why then when they reached out for comment and said
this is the story we're running with, why was this not cleared
up? They reached to both they reached out to both Chorus and
the guy who was in this. did a screenshot from a slideshow shared
with Wired follows the article's publication
a lawyer with chorus that offers several talking points if a
member of the cohort want to discuss chorus publicly >> they
reach out foration
>> they reach out for comment pre-ublication why can I
ask you did they not comment pre-publication
>> I don't know but either way it's false
>> it's not false the information they had >> you
can talk about chorus publicly >> no you sorry you can't
discuss your >> Can you or can you not speak about chorus
publicly your relationship you they are saying so I believe this
is entirely true that the contracts they looked at had language
that said the creators will not publicize the relationship with
chorus because Wired has a literal like uh has a journalistic
like eth a journalistic what you call it like um like ethical
commitment. They wouldn't just lie about this. >> This
is factually correct. the contract they reviewed. Notice what
I said. Notice what I said. Hold up. What did I say? Did I say
that they lied or did I say it was false? >> You said this
is false. >> Yes. So, it is it false. >> The contract
is false.
>> No. What I'm saying is the contracts reviewed by wires
prohibits standard partnership disclosures declaring that creators
will not publicize the relationship with chorus. I do not think
this is false because I think that would be them publishing a
lie. Now whether or not this happens in reality that you can't
talk about it. You assume? No. No. So, you know, you understand
you understand that they could publicize uh they could uh again,
and this is what the chick gets into that the wording of the
legal ease might uh uh stipulate one thing or imply one thing,
but in material reality, in practicality, it doesn't enable them
to actually like it's it's not actionable. Right. >> I
don't sorry, what did you that like >> So, when you write
a contract, you give yourself the maximum legal latitude. However,
you don't intend on making uh >> that's totally fine. You
give you give yourself the maximum legal latitude. The criticism
here is of the contract. Why then when they respond to this do
they say that this is debunked when it's a claim about the contract
instead of just saying actually while we do put that in the contract
explicitly and that's kind of weird we tell people that here's
how you disclose it and and here's us showing how you disclose
it. Why do they attack the the credibility of both this publication
and the author instead of just expressing a clarification? Why
when they were reached out to for
clarification which is that they're allowed to talk about chorus
publicly. >> Uh they're allowed to talk about chorus um
discuss chorus publicly. This does not say their partnership
with chorus publicly. That does not say that if you want to discuss.
>> So I I do so I don't believe it's contested that they
can talk about is your argument that they can't discuss any relationship
with course publicly. >> Argument is that they can't do
it without course's prior written consent prior express consent
which is what's written in the article. >> Yeah. No no
because it says with or publicize their relationship
um or or tell others without uh chorus's prior expressed consent.
Yeah. express consent in this context. >> The claim.
>> Sure. Yeah. This has always been the claim. Yes, that
is the claim. Yes. I don't disagree that that is the claim. But
their their relationship, they're allowed to publicize their
relationship, right? Why? Again, if you're >> because uh
we had talked about this earlier. If the clear implication, if
the clear implication is they're only expressly talking about
uh the incubator
>> then why are they to in this context having to post
an update in the context of whether or not they can talk about
chorus at all publicly and they're not even stating chorus explicitly?
They're stating the uh incub sorry they're not stating explicitly
the incubator. They're stating chorus.
So again, people who sign the contract with the incubator cannot
declare will not sorry will not publicly or will not publicize
the relationship with course or tell others that they're members
of the program without COR's prior express consent. The update
they give isn't even conflicting with this. The update they give
is here's a way that we've preapproved with our lawyers for you
to talk about this. This is literally all consistent with the
article and and it claims the entire problem with that because
my problem with this is that it's implying that it's a bad thing.
Wouldn't you need to know the manners in which they can talk
about it publicly? What is the issue with this? >> Um they're
not saying that they can disclose. They still haven't said that
they can disclose their financial thing. And ethically, I think
they should be financially disclosing any financial arrangement
that comes with obligations. financial arrangements like when
when they're talking need to know the manner in which they're
allowed to discuss it >> because let's say inside of those
screenshots or in inside of various things that they're allowed
to talk about that they're being paid or they got gifts or they
got uh equipment from chorus wouldn't that be the principal
>> why would Graham Wilson not make that expressly clear
in these things so it says that they're able to talk disc if
they wanted to discuss uh course publicly, they offer several
talking points.
Why would wired say if they want to talk about chorus publicly
and not make it clear that it's about the uh like how to talk
about how you're being paid or that you're getting paid, >> Because
one how you discuss chorus publicly could include whether or
not you're being paid by chorus publicly.
>> Okay, then why would they not update this to to say
that uh like when the update comes through here, it's discuss
chorus publicly, right? I don't know why the update isn't specific,
right? >> I don't know either. I would want I would want
to see the update and I would want to see principally how this
uh
actually functioned >> from Wilson of course placing restrictions
on content. I don't know why this isn't publish published by
the way. I just wish they would publish this specifically this
slide.
I wonder if he asked them to not publish this. I think I if if
I had to imagine and it's kind of a part of what the chick's
video and her response is about is that it's because there's
uh legal ease inside of the contract and I imagine this is probably
the reason why uh part of the reason why the contract isn't public
is there's legal ease inside of these contracts that make it
look uh not good look make it look pretty bad but in material
reality to how these things actually operate. We have no reason
to believe that you can't do the various things that
uh uh people would want them to do e ethically. >> Okay.
Then if chorus if chorus is saying that you can actually disclose
these partnerships and here's how and they could just quell this.
Why would they not just publish that? >> Wait because it
is how they're they're it's not in the wording of their contract.
It's in how their contract is
>> Sure. But why would they just say this is like we're
putting on the record this is how the contract's exercised. >> Isn't
that literally what Brian Tyler Cohen has literally done or whatever
his name is?
>> he's literally said he's literally said that no there's
no >> that people can be transparent. People can talk about
how they're getting paid. This is the reality of he's gone on
and said yeah yeah you can talk about being paid. You can talk
you can criticize the Dems. He he broke down these things and
you can say that he was not talking about this that you wanted
him to, but he refuted it. He said that this wasn't the case.
He just didn't go like this stipulation in the contract isn't
real. This stipulation he just said that you're allowed to criticize
the dems. You're allowed to disclose stuff. >> Yeah. Again,
we're talking about we're talking about disclosing um like funding,
right? >> Did he not say that? I I maybe maybe I'm wrong.
Somebody correct me if I'm wrong. I thought he said that >> maybe
if he did if if you're just blanket allowed to do that, I don't
know why they wouldn't just make it clear or or publish this
explicit like slide that they had where it's like, "Oh, you can
disclose your funding." >> No, because like I said, I don't
think it's I don't think it's in the legal ease. I don't think
it's necessarily in a slide. I imagine it's on a case- by case
basis. You ask like, "Hey, can I disclose how much money I'm
being paid?" Or, uh, you know, "Hey," be like, "Hey, I want to
talk about how much money I'm getting paid." And they're just
like, "Yeah, sure." And just not very many people do it because
nobody wants to do >> Well, it's not even
just be like, "Yeah, I'm getting paid $3,500 a month." >> Yeah.
Okay. Um I think we're mostly coming down to the same thing on
this. I want to go through just her TikTok to get to the You
said it's I think it's this next part possibly. You said it's
before 5 minutes >> Then I'm probably going to wrap stream
because we're at 9 hours 15 already. But >> streamer to
lose his job. >> I'll take your pick. I have heard of contracts
that exist that restrict what people can say bad about Democrats,
but this is not one of them. This contract actually has no bearing
on a single thing that we ever post. Which brings me to my next
section. And like I have 100% confidence in this because I think
if they had contracts like that, they would be getting like run
into the ground. Like the the FEC would run a train on them if
they had contracts that said you can't criticize Democrats as
like this financial structure, they would literally get like
triple penetrated into the ground as a organization. Like it
would be over for them. >> Next part, and this is a really
important part. I'm going to try to explain this as well as I
can, but feel free to comment questions, is that the contracts
reviewed by Wired prohibit standard partnership disclosures.
What she's talking about, okay, a standard partnership disclosure
is when you make a video in partnership with an org like the
ACLU and so then you put ACLU partner as a disclosure in your
caption. There is very important context left out of this article
of why the standard disclosures aren't the kind we use at Chorus
and that's because Chorus never pays us to make a video. The
author of this article actually said that in a comment. You're
correct that Chorus doesn't pay you to post specific content.
Chorus is a training program where I learn things like what lights
to buy if I want to film a YouTube video and what policy experts
are saying about Jerry Mandering in Texas. >> I'm so glad
that they paid this lady $8,000 to be like this is how you buy
a ring light. That's a fantastic use of money, isn't it? $8,000.
This is you buy this ring light. Actually, that's awesome.
Hold on. >> 1630. I I don't I don't think it's exclusively
that, but it's also like
paying money for them to be able to potentially get like editors
and stuff like that, right? I think I remember people talking
about Yeah. So that that $8,000 is pennies compared to setting
up a whole operation like that, right? >> Uh not necessarily
pennies, but I think
>> is pennies. >> How much do you think Cooper pays
for her setup? >> You think it's more or less than $8,000?
>> Oh, you're talking about like a nicer setup? Sure. Sure.
Sure. For sure. Sure. >> Yeah. I'm I'm laughing. >> Hold
on. That's what these people laughing at her example. I'm laughing
at her example. Her example is like goofy. But her example, >> they
tell me what lighting to buy and it's like a picture of a ring
light. I'm sorry. It's just a goofy. >> Fair enough. Fair
enough. Fair enough. >> Garden DC. So since Chorus is about
like personal development and they're never paying you to make
a video, of course you're not putting like chorus partnership
in your caption. That's not how that would work. So, I don't
fault anyone who read the sentence and was like, "That is so
evil." Because a lot of people who consume content don't >> Do
you agree that that is if she's Wait, do you first of all, do
we agree she's telling the truth? And do you think that's like
fair?
>> I think this is way more about um like they don't want
uh # chorus partner or something or # chorus on content because
they'll run into FC violations because they know the people they're
paying are mostly doing content that would place them in a partisan
or electioneering category. I think that's why they don't want
it because they know they're paying people to do political speech
in that explicit way. >> I think that's what >> you
could say that's more over I guess their their issue I or their
like idea. But do you think that this is like >> I mean
it's obviously unethical. The question is like whether or not
it's unethical given that you feel like >> I don't I don't
think it's necessarily unethical. If they're allowed to disclose
that they're partnered or that they're uh in the chorus program,
but they just can't put it on their actual
>> Sure. If that's all it is. Yeah, if that's all it is.
But I think um >> that's what a standard partnership disclosure
is. Do you disagree with >> It's all without it's all without
course prior written consent. So, I'm going to see if she if
she's saying that we could totally disclose this without their
>> The logistics of like >> No, no, no. >> No,
no, no. What I'm asking is,
do you think that what she said there is unethical that them
not requiring that you put or that you're not supposed to put
on your >> Yeah. It's it's disallowing,
right? >> Yes. Do you think that is unethical? intrinsically
unethical
>> uh to block like a uh standard disclosure. I think so.
I think it's like unethical to block. >> Okay. So, you
So, I I disagree because I think that what you should be able
to do is just go I am partnered with
uh like on your Twitter bio or your stream thing, I am partnered
with uh uh
or it probably be in your Twitter bio that you are like affiliated
with Chorus and that should be sufficient. I don't think you
should have to put in every single bit of your content that
>> you're partnered with that because I also don't think
that makes sense because then that would be attaching their brand
to every single thing that you say >> which just isn't
really how that works.
>> Yeah. Uh, I think so. I've always thought the talking
point was really compelling that for a politician who accepts
lobbying funding, you have a patch and they look like NASCAR
drivers with the the coats on, right? You ever you ever found
that talking point compelling that like basically you take money
and you should have like advertising on your Congress uniform
like commensurate with how much money you take like the the ratio
of money? >> I could be I think that could be like fun
or funny. Um, >> I think it would actually be good that
you knew that you knew where people's biases were, where they're
getting their money from, how they're getting reelected, so that
you know to like basically couch certain opinions from them in
certain ways, right? >> I broadly think if people are getting
paid by so here would be direct analogy because I don't think
that's a good analogy. Direct analogy would be is if you're a
Congress person and you accept money from a donor, you are literally
tattooed on your face that you accept money for instance from
Apac where you can't take it off no matter where you go. Well,
no. That's the argument, right? Because the argument that she's
making and or argument the basis for it is that on a not on every
single piece of content that you ever make into perpetuity, as
long as you're under this contract, you have to put partnered
with this group. I think that's ridiculous. I think you should
be able to just
like the idea of having a perpetualized or a perpetual thing.
I'm saying that if somebody wanted to do that somebody wanted
to disclose that if they felt like it was ethical to do that,
I think they could do that on whatever content they wanted to.
>> I think they could do that. I think I think it's unethical
to say you from >> No, I don't I don't I don't think that
makes sense because they don't want to associate their brand
with really any any particular political content that
>> that you are. I don't think they want to have to go
through the processing political influencers.
>> Then why are they sponsoring political
>> Not because they endorse every single last thing that
they do or could do, but because that like as a content creator,
they are probably what? Anti-Trump, if I had to guess, is probably
going to be the primary criteria.
>> I um I think pro-democracy is what they're saying is
the cope. Um
but how do I put this? I think uh
hold on prodemocracy is the cope and
I I just think that they explicitly don't want them disclosing
this because it will run into they I think they're paying for
that content. They are paying obviously you're paying somebody
$8,000 who's basically only operating on TikTok. You are making
them you are probably the majority of the money they're making,
right? I would imagine >> you are the majority of the money
they're making. >> Yes. If you're paying somebody $8,000
a month who's only on Tik Tok with 100,000 subs or 200,000 followers,
I think she's pretty big on Tik Tok. But I think if this is all
she's got on Tik Tok, okay, no, 655K. I thought it was 100, but
655K on Tik Tok, but she's not getting like insane views. I don't
think she's making, you know, thousands of dollars a month. She
might be making one, two, $3,000 a month, right? Tik Tok's like
pennies, right? I've heard Tik Tok you make nothing. >> I
heard Tik Tok actually got way better. I'm not going to say exactly
who, but I knew somebody who had like a Tik Tok get like I think
it was like a million views or something and they got paid like
300 bucks. It's actually pretty crazy.
>> Um, yeah, but then I So, I would say that then 80 million
likes. So, 80 million times uh 300
80 time 300 >> Sorry, views not likes views.
>> Oh, so less than that. More than that. 5.3 million.
I don't know how you find views. I'm trying to find like social
blade or something for Tik Tok. Do I got Tik Tok here? Oh, I
do have Tik Tok. Hold on, Alex. >> This was more recently.
This was like six or 9 months ago. I don't remember how long
it was ago, but they said explicitly that they had been posting
on Tik Tok and they weren't making money and then all of a sudden
they started making money. So, they they seem to imply it was
a change. But none nonethe
matter to our conversation. the uh I I I don't think it's unethical
to avoid standard partnership disclosures, right? Well, for instance,
do you think my partnership with Progressive Victory was
>> Uh I think it would be unethical if they told you you
couldn't disclose it. Yeah. >> No. What I'm saying is I
wasn't
uh required and nor did I put on every single tweet, nor on every
single short, nor on every single YouTube
is an ethical requirement. I think saying that somebody couldn't
do that, saying we don't want you disclosing, I think that is
unethical.
>> The disallowing because the disallowing of that disclosure
in any way to me feels unethical.
>> Because because you should be able to disclose that
you're making money from >> You can. They already have
a list of how you can disclose that. >> But I'm saying
you should be able to say, "I'm being paid to make political
content."
That's what you're being paid for, right? >> So, no. No,
no, no. You don't need to have hashtagsponsored
on your content to show you're getting paid to make content.
>> I don't need to. But if somebody felt like that was
their ethical obligation to say, I'm getting most of my salary
from somebody with a political interest and I think it's my ethical
responsib.
>> Yeah, but people might not click through to your bio.
They might only see the video. And if somebody feels it's their
ethical responsibility to do it, I think it's unethical to tell
them they can't.
>> Okay. Um, that's fine. I don't think that's a big deal.
I I think that doesn't matter literally at all. And I would actually
argue that it makes total sense on behalf of whatever group that
you should not have to literally endorse every single video that
that person makes into like in totality. Um, I think that's ridiculous.
Um, I think that they should be able to reserve the right to
be like, "Hey, no, we don't want you making content with our
name attached to it, but you can disclose that you're getting
paid by us as like >> I think they should limit how much
they're paying people to like a like a tenth of their income
that they make from actual like content creation because otherwise
they are if they're a significant portion of their income, I
am worried that the interests of that group will be like pursued
by the person who's getting you know 90% % of their income from
that group. I I think that is a concern and I think somebody
might ethically think, okay, if I'm getting a huge chunk of my
income from this, I think it's >> I got to give them my
tax return before I accept this stuff. What the >> Who
said that? >> You just said limiting to limiting X amount
based on their income. So, I got to give them my tax return.
>> I'm saying like, okay, that would be like a goal. You
could do it based on views and how much you project they make
or something, right? >> Do you understand what I'm saying?
Hold on. Do do you understand that I'm like I'm just going for
like a >> You understand? I'm just going for like a standard,
right? >> I don't think that's nor do I think that's
impractical. It's impractical. It's impractical. I'm not trying
to give you something practical. I'm literally just giving you
like a a standard for if I'm giving you 90% of your income and
you feel like I feel like if I'm giving you 90% of your income
for your political you're a political content creator. I find
you I'm a political activist group. I'm giving you 90% of your
income. I understand that you might want to say to disclose to
everybody on everything you do that you're getting most of your
money from me and I think it's unethical for unethical for me
to block you from doing >> That's not what's being blocked
in the standard partnership disclosure. >> The only thing
that's being blocked is every single time that you make a piece
of content. I don't have to filter out whether or not you put
my name on it. >> I said that. >> I just say you
can't don't put my name on any of the content you make. But you
can put my name on your Twitter bio and you can put my name anywhere
here and say that you're paid by me. >> Yeah, I we just
disagree. I think it's unethical to disallow, but is I we're
just talking in circles. It's okay.
>> Um I think it's just unethical to disallow that. And
I think they're doing it I think they're doing it because they're
skirting FC
is more optimal, but like >> they're just they're just
skirting campaign finance law, right? >> Like that's that's
what's going on and that's why it's unethical. I I genuinely
don't know enough about campaign finance law to know whether
or not that would even skirt the lines of campaign finance law
or not. >> I think people who are more honest about this
who have done the analysis like people who are a part of this
basically say that yeah it's them avoiding avoiding that most
likely. >> I don't know what the campaign finance law is
and I would reckon that many of the people commenting on this
don't >> Okay. Um
yeah, I don't know a lot. I've just know I know enough that I've
like looked into a couple of these structures and I think these
things have to say explicitly nonpartisan and can't be involved
in electioneering like specifically with chorus media and I think
basically they have a bunch of people who would get involved
in electioneering who would endorse candidates and they have
to write a contract that prevents them from having their name
attached to content that endorses candidates because if they
have enough of that happening then they will be like basically
fined or possibly like disbanded by the FCC. That's that's likely
to me what the actual concern is here. But nobody's talking about
what the actual concern is in my opinion. I think they're talking
mostly about other >> I think they're talking about the
article, man. >> Uh yeah. Well, I I actually think they're
not talking about the article. I think they're talking about
what Hassan's saying about the article. >> And this of
the people who do that, I don't think that's wrong either because
what people like Hassan are doing is they're creating a perception
of the article that uh that it needs to be combed. I don't think
it's wrong to do that. I don't think it's wrong to combat Hassan.
I think it's wrong to go and say Taylor Loren loves Candace Owens
and Dr. Carlson instead of coming up with a tangible statement
of your own. >> I mean, they have they have come up with
tangible statements of their own. >> I think most of this
is cope and most of this is actually not even remotely disproven
by the stuff they're saying. I think this person was explicitly
lying in a ton of this video. >> I think I think they're
explicitly pointing to things I think they're explicitly pointing
to things before they signed this contract and saying this is
proof that um this contract isn't enforced. I think they're explicitly
doing that. >> All right. Okay, cool. Uh, all right. Just
uh the last little bit here and then the video's done labels
work. But I am frustrated at the author of this article for not
adding like the relevant context here because she is not supposed
to publish an article unless it's been like very fact checked
and contextualized. And this was like very misleading. And then
I also highlighted the section, I accidentally talked about it
already earlier in the video, the you know creators will not
publicize the relationship with Chorus or tell others they're
member of the program without Chorus's prior express consent.
This is the protecting small creators part, but also lots of
things in contracts are written very strict in case of legal
emergency. I've told plenty of people casually that I'm in chorus
and chorus does not care. They've expressly told us that that's
fine. This is just for if someone does something like diabolically
evil and then chorus has to sue them and they can just be like,
"Girl, the contract like it makes it easier in court." They don't
really care about it otherwise. It's not top secret. If you want
more examples of people who've publicly talked about for a while,
>> do you think that's a lie?
>> Yeah. I think that's a lie. I think I think basically
the reason they do this is again all the stuff around FC.
>> Yeah. I I think >> Yeah. So I basically my thoughts
on this are essentially that they're trying to maintain their
status as a 501c4 while doing things that are explicitly like
partisan political. >> She is lying about the fact that
she can just casually drop that she's a part of chorus. She's
lying about that. >> No, but I think she's been a part
of chorus from the beginning. And I don't think it's about chorus.
I think there
express ways that the lawyers have okayed them to talk about
chorus. >> That is that is an update in the article, right?
That the lawyer said, "Here's the way." So again, it's without
their express. That's the claim in the article, right? Without
their express consent. And I've seen nobody dispute
>> because they don't want to have their name. Exactly
what she said. They don't want to have their name attached to
some insane thing that you say. So, it's like, hey, we're putting
this in here in case you say some insane
and we reserve the right to go, hey, we at Chorus uh condemn
this and we don't uh consent to our name being attached to this
content. >> Um, yeah, I mean, you could say that. I don't
think you have to do a contract that prevents disclosures. I
think you could you could come up with some other language there.
I assume I assume you shouldn't say, "Oh, you have to get our
our okay on everything." Um, and I think the the effect of that
is a lack of disclosure and way fewer disclosures on the part
of the creators, which I think is just going ethically in the
wrong direction.
Right. I I don't think you disagree that the effect of those
contract clauses is way fewer disclosures on the part of creators.
>> Hang on. >> I don't think you disagree that the
effect of having that contract clause in there that says you
shouldn't do this without express consent is way fewer disclosures
on the part of creators. a way more opaque like political funding
within creator spaces. >> Sorry, you're asking if it's
>> I think the effect of I think the effect of this is
that creators will not disclose funding that the effect of this.
They will not they will not get consent. It will it will lead
to a total a total uh what is it? Is it der is darth lack of
I think a total der of uh >> I think it is I don't I don't
think that's the case. >> Because I have no reason to believe
that would be the case. Why would I believe that nobody would
disclose it? I didn't say nobody. I said way fewer. Like I think
I think it I think it absolutely hinders and and eliminates disclosure.
Like I think basically no if something
it I don't see any reason to believe that there would be people
who would believe they can't disclose it. >> Okay. So if
that slideshow comes out and says here's how you can talk about
how you're getting paid by chorus. I would totally agree with
you. I don't think that's what it's going to say but we'd have
to wait until we see it.
>> What do you think it would Do you think it says >> I
think it's going to say here's how you could talk about the fact
that you work with chorus and it's not going to make any mention
of you getting paid or the cohorts or whatever's going on. >> that's
what I believe.
But I Hey, I could be wrong on a lot of this. This is my read
going through this whole thing from the beginning. Um yeah. Yep.
I would love to see that slide. I'm looking forward to that slide
getting posted. I have a feeling this isn't really going to go
away that quickly and I'm excited to see how it will go. Bro,
what the using this Trump picture? There's no way. This has to
be edited, right? This guy is dying. There's no way. This is
edited. This is fake. This is fake. >> Yeah, that's that's
super edited. There's no way he's not that fat, but he's not
that fat. All right. >> This like doesn't even look fat.
It's like looks like he's gassing up. Okay. He's like getting
filled with some kind of This guy's about to pop. This guy's
a >> Uh I got to go to bed, bro. >> Yeah, me too.
All right. We'll talk to you later. Thanks for the chat. >> Yep.
Much loved. Bye. >> Good night. Good night. Okay. Good
night, guys. Bye. See you later. See you later. See you later.
Good night.